la parole est à Madame Catherine Colona
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères si Monsieur min et Monsieur
Cordier sont là tout va
bien la maison merci à vous madame la
ministre vous avez la parole merci
madame la Présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés il est important
de pouvoir débattre dans cet hémicycle
des relations que la France entretient
avec les pays d'Afrique il s'agit d'une
priorité de notre politique étrangère il
est donc légitime d'y associer
pleinement la représentation nationale
tout aussi légitimes sont les
questionnements qu'ont pu susciter les
différentes crises qui se sont succédées
au Sahel je reviendrai plus en détail
tout à l'heure sur notre action depuis
10 ans concernant cette zone mais je
vaux d'abord insister sur un point
essentiel l'attitude à notre égard de
trois jeintes militaires ne doit pas
occulter les bonnes relations et je
dirais même les très bonnes relations
que nous entretenons avec l'immense
majorité des pays africains ils sont
54 ce serait donc une erreur une grave
erreur que de réduire l'Afrique qui est
diverse et vaste au sol
Sahel je commencerai donc par ce qui
concerne la grande majorité de nos
relations avec les pays africains et
donc par ce qui va bien car sous
l'impulsion constante du président de la
République nous avons voulu renouveler
notre politique à l'égard du continent
africain et ce renouvellement porte ses
fruits vous vous demanderez peut-être
mesdames et messieurs les députés pour
quelle raison l'Afrique constitue l'une
des grandes priorités de notre
diplomatie la réponse part d'un constat
simple l'Afrique est un continent qui
émerge sur le plan économique sur le
plan diplomatique sur le plan
démographique bien sûr avec une
population de plus d'un milliard
d'habitants en passe de doubler d'ici
2050 et de quadruplé d'ici
2100 pour aller jusqu'à représenter le
quart environ de la population mondiale
dans les années à venir elle va compter
de plus en plus dans les grands
équilibres du monde dans la croissance
mondiale dans la création dans
l'innovation et c'est aussi en Afrique
que se joue l'avenir de la Francophonie
l'Afrique c'est aussi le continent où
vivent plus d'un million de Français
dans nos régions et départements de
Mayotte et de la réunion sans oublier
nos 130000 compatriotes qui résident
dans des pays d'Afrique
subsaharienne parce que nous avons
besoin de nos partenaires africains pour
résoudre les grands défis qui nous
attendent pour la paix pour la sécurité
pour l'adaptation au changement
climatique il est indispensable que la
France nous des relations solides
confiantes avec les gouvernements et
avec les sociétés
africaines il y a encore quelques années
notre dialogue se limitait trop aux
crises régionales qui affectait
l'Afrique aujourd'hui nous entretenons
un dialogue étroit et exigeant aussi sur
l'ensemble de nos sujets d'intérêt
commun la guerre en Ukraine le climat
les forêts la réforme de la gouvernance
mondiale et c'est exactement ce que nous
avons fait en juin dernier à Paris lors
du sommet pour un nouveau pacte
financier mondial auquel ont participé
notamment 20 chefs d'État
africains pour autant la France est
toujours aussi engagée pour aider à
résoudre les crises du continent en
soutien aux organisations régionales je
pense en particulier au terribles
conflit dans l'est de l' RDC ou au
Soudan où nous restons en contact avec
les deux camps pour faciliter un
processus de paix durable et je l'ai
fait encore par exemple hier avec mon
homologue de RDC ce matin avec celui du
Rwanda compte tenu de la remontée des
tensions dans l'Est de la RDC la France
accompagne également le processus de
sortie de crise en Éthiopie par exemple
je me suis rendu en janvier dernier avec
mon homologue allemande annaalena
berbock et nous pouvons également être
fier du chemin qui a été parcouru avec
le Ronda grâce un travail de mémoire
honnête et un engagement diplomatique
volontariste qui nous ont permis de
relancer nos partenariats atéraux
mesdames et messieurs les députés notre
diplomatie a un objectif principal en
Afrique c'est que la France soit un
partenaire crédible compétitif et
également attractif aussi bien pour les
acteurs économiques que pour les
étudiants les artistes les créateurs et
en général pour l'ensemble des sociétés
civiles car il faut le dire et le
répéter nos entreprises sont
compétitives en Afrique elles le
prouvent chaque jour jour la France est
aujourd'hui le deuxè investisseur
étranger en Afrique en 15 ans le nombre
de filiales d'entreprises françaises en
Afrique a doublé de même que nos
investissements nous aidons nos
start-ups nos PME et des entrepreneurs
de la diaspora investir sur le continent
en finançant leurs projets ou en
facilitant leur accès au marché
africain un exemple et et un seul
j'étais il y a deux ou tro semaine au
Nigéria dans cet immense pays de plus de
216 millions d'habitants qui sera le 3èe
pays le plus peuplé au monde en 2050
nous avons doublé nos investissements en
an j'ai bien conscience que ce constat
et ces faits vont à rebours de bien des
idées
reçues les réflexes pavloviens les
images d'Épinal ont un point commun
voudrait nous faire croire que tout va
forcément mal en Afrique et que la
France est forcément à la traain et
pourtant il faut bien se rendre compte
que nos jeunesses en particulier qu'elle
soi française ou africaine s'intéresse à
tout ce qui permettra de rendre le monde
de demain plus juste plus vivable plus
durable et à tous les partenariats qui
peuvent y contribuer elles ont raison et
c'est pour elles que nous
travaillons la réalité de notre
politique en Afrique c'est notre volonté
d'investir dans avenir dans les secteurs
les plus prometteurs pour l'économie de
demain dans la vitalité de ce continent
qui est le continent le plus jeune du
monde un continent où 60 % de la
population a moins de 25 ans à cet égard
la priorité donné aux industries
culturelles et créatives est exemplaire
depuis la bande dessiné jusqu'aux jeux
vidéo en passant par la production
audiovisuelle par le espport ou par les
univers immersifs ces industries sont
porte à la fois de croissance économique
d'émancipation individuelle et de
renouvellement de nos imaginaires c'est
pourquoi ils ont en Afrique un potentiel
considérable des succès d'ors et déjà
impressionnants et c'est pourquoi la
France entend se positionner comme une
un partenaire de de référence en la
matière c'est ce que nous avons fait
avec le premier forum international
création Africa qui a réuni à Paris tout
début octobre des centaines
d'entrepreneurs français africains les
plus à la pointe j'ai lancé
parallèlement moi-même cette année avec
mon ministère un fond de 20 millions
d'euros pour que nos ambassades puissent
soutenir directement artistes et
créateurs du continent qui veulent
développer leurs entreprises sur le
marché régional aussi bien que sur le
marché international et enfin avec la
future Maison des mondes africains nous
voulons que Paris devienne l'un des
cœurbattants de la créativité africaine
mais c'est aussi par son investissement
solidaire que la France est un
partenaire crédible de l'émergence du
continent depuis 2017 notre aide
publique au développement est passé vous
le savez de 10 à 15 milliards d'euros
avec plus de 5 milliards par an pour
l'Afrique nous sommes désormais le 4e
bailleur mondial nous avons dépassé le
Royaume-Uni et surtout surtout nous
sommes le seul pays à avoir augmenté ses
financements en direction du continent
l'an dernier notre attractivité reste
aussi très importante pour les étudiants
africains c'est-à-dire pour les élites
de demain la France est la première
destination des étudiants africains ils
sont désormais près de 95000 à faire le
choix de nos universités en augmentation
forte augmentation de 40 % depuis
2017 nos ambassades mènent un travail
remarquable de promotion des études en
France pour les étudiants africains
notamment pour attiré en complément des
étudiants francophones des étudiants
anglophones et j'en fais moi-même le
constat en juin dernier lors de mon
déplacement en Afrique du Sud oui nous
sommes attractifs pour les étudiants qui
sont les élites de demain des pays
africains mais la France est aussi
résolument du côté des démocrates
africains ça n'implique nullement de
donner des leçons ni de s'ingérer dans
les affaires intérieures des pays
africain ça consiste à aider les acteurs
engagés de la société civile comme par
exemple la Fondation d'innovation pour
la démocratie dirigé par le professeur
haschil membé mais aussi d'aider tous
les influenceurs tous les journalistes
africains qui luttent contre la
désinformations qui lutteent pour une
information de qualité condition on le
sait sineéquanon de société ouverte et
démocratique j'ai évidemment en tête les
grifes souvent entendu et et classique
autour de la délivrance des
visas je dois vous dire que nous
rénovons en ce moment même notre
politique de visas pour mieux tenir
compte de nos objectifs d'attractivité
de rayonnement et de prévention des
migrations illégales dans le cadre de la
feuille de route dont j'ai fixé les
contours avec Gérald
darana depuis les engagements pris par
le Président de la République à
wagadougou en 2017 engagement réitéré au
sommet de Montpellier en 2021 et en
encore en février dernier dans son
discours prononcé à l'Élysée nous
réinventons notre manière de travailler
avec nos partenaires africains nous
voulons bâtir vous le savez des
partenariats qui soient des partenariats
respectueux responsables où chacun
assume ses intérêts réciproques un
partenariat fait d'écoute et de dialogue
un partenariat qui implique aussi de
briser certains tabou nous l'avons fait
comme le tabou de la restitution des
œuvres un partenariat qui permet de
regarder notre passé en face nous
l'avons fait aussi avec le Randa ou avec
le Cameroun par exemple et un
partenariat enfin qui s'appuie qui sait
s'appuyer sur nos atouts je pense
notamment au rôle de nos diasporas mais
aussi je le répète alors que nous
accueillerons en 2024 le Sommet de la
Francophonie à cette langue française
que nous avons en partage avec des
millions et des millions
d'Africains cette méthode est la bonne
Mesdames et Messieurs les déput nous
entendons la poursuivre et nous la
poursuivrons j'en suis convaincu comme
l'ensemble du gouvernement et comme tous
nos agents déployés sur le continent qui
mettent en œuvre cette politique avec
détermination conviction et
volontarisme mais parce que j'en appelis
tout à l'heure au devoir de
lucidité il faut aussi considérer ce qui
se passe dans trois pays Burkina Faso
Mali Niger et j'iniste trois pays sur 54
mais trois pays quand même et trois
relations complexes sur lesquelles je
voudrais maintenant
revenir depuis 10 ans notre pays a
consenti de très importants efforts sur
le plan militaire financier politique
diplomatique jusqu'au sacrifice de nos
soldats le ministre des armées en
reparlera et je veux avant lui s'il m'y
autorise saluer mais avec vous mesdames
et messieurs les députés la mémoire des
disparus et le courage de nos forces
armées en
2013 merci pour
eux merci en 2013 à la demande des
autorités du Mali et des pays de la
région le président Hollande a pris la
décision courageuse d'engager nos forces
armées nos militaires ont combattu avec
bravour ils ont contribué à éviter que
le Mali ne devienne un état terroriste
et nous pouvons être fiers de ce qui a
été accompli à à cet égard alors
j'entends parfois que nous aurions trop
investi sur le volet militaire et pas
assez investi sur le développement et
sur la diplomatie et je vous le dis
clairement c'est faux notre
investissement pour le développement au
Sahel depuis
2013 période de référence a été massif
ce sont 3 milliards et demi d'euros
d'aidees bilatéral en 10 ans qui ont été
apportés et à 80 % sous forme de don
entre 2012 et 2022 notre aide annuel
pour le Sahel a doublé elle n'a pas
diminué elle n pas augmenté elle a
doublé alors qu'on dise pas qu'on a
négligé le volet développement et
parallèlement la France a investi un
capital diplomatique considérable à
Bruxelles notamment pour convaincre les
Européens de s'impliquer tous n'avait
pas la même relation avec les pays
africains que nous et nous avons eu des
résultats concrets avec de l'aide plus
de 7 milliards d'aide européenne au
Sahel sur 10 ans s'ajoutant au 3
milliards et demi d'euros d'aide
française pour le sel en 10 an avec
aussi l'intervention directe y compris
l'intervention militaire de certains
pays européens qui jusqu'ici n'étaient
pas
intervenus fortement en Afrique je veux
citer par exemple l'Estonie
ou la République tchèque dans takuba ou
encore l'Allemagne dans la min où jeis
encore citer l'alliance Sael grâce à
laquelle nous avons fédéré 27 bailleurs
internationaux qui ont investi dans la
région comme jamais auparavant effort
diplomatique européen effort
diplomatique auprès de l'ONU également
pour créer puis chaque année pour
renouveler le mandat de la minusma et au
moment où vous le savez les derniers
Casques Bleus quittent le Mali dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et
alors que 310 d'entre eux ont perdu la
vie depuis 2013 pour cette mission je
veux saluer le travail mené par la
Mission des Nations Unies et enfin nous
n'avons pas ménagé nos efforts non plus
pour convaincre les autorités du Mali
d'appliquer l'accord d'Alger améliorer
la gouvernance rétablir les services de
l'État sur l'ensemble du
territoire nous l'avons dit nous l'avons
répété nous les avons encouragé mais
s'il y a bien un enseignement à tirer de
la crise au Sahel c'est que la gouver
est fondamentale les partenaires
extérieurs peuvent aider encourager
inciter mais ne peuvent pas se
substituer aux autorités locales ni ne
le
doivent aujourd'hui les coups d'État
survenus au Mali au Burkina et tout
dernièrement au Niger fragilise tous les
efforts consentis depuis 2013 la
situation sécuritaire s'est
dégradée la crise humanitaire est
dramatique et les violations des
libertés multiplie et faire le choix de
Wagner comme l'a fait le Malie c'est de
sur croix faire le choix de la prédation
économique et des crimes de
guerre contrairement à ce que certains
voudraient nous faire croire par leur
propagande ces jeintes ne sont pas
motivé par une volonté de rupture avec
la France elles sont motivées en réalité
par une logique de rupture avec
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale il faudrait le voir
clairement à commencé par la rupture
avec leurs voisins avec les
organisations régionales avec les
Nations Unies et ce n'est pas tant la
France qui est visée que tout un système
international de coopération et de
valeur dont ces régimes s'écartent et
qui leur sert de bouc
émissaire alors oui mesdames et
messieurs les députés face à de tels
régimes nous ne pouvons pas maintenir
nos coopérations comme si de rien
n'était nous ne pouvons pas poursuivre
la lutte antiterroriste avec des
bouchistes nous ne pouvons pas financer
des projets de dévelop
qui les entretiennent mais bien sûr nous
maintenons notre aide humanitaire pour
ne pas faire payer aux populations les
comportement de leur dirigeants du
moment et contrairement à ce qu'on a pu
lire ici ou là je le redit monsieur le
député leco nous maintenons nos
coopérations avec les sociétés civiles
avec les étudiants avec les artistes et
je veux le redire clairement ils sont
toujours les bienvenus en France et
surtout au regard de la longue histoire
que nous avons avec ces pays nous tenons
à maintenir les liens
avec nos sociétés et ils viennent
aujourd'hui nous devons et c'est notre
responsabilité prendre de la hauteur
pour regarder la situation en face toute
la région est déstabilisée voilà ce qui
se passe et alors que notre retrait
militaire du Niger marque la fin de 10
années de lutte antiterroriste au Sahel
nous devons maintenant complètement
repenser l'architecture de sécurité dans
cette région nous nous y employons avec
les pays africains avec les partenaires
européens avec le partenair américains
mais une chose est sûre et vous avez
entendu le président de la République
vous entendrez également le ministre des
Armées ce n'est plus à la France de
porter seu ou presque seule la lourde
charge de l'action antiterroriste en
Afrique de l'Ouest c'est au pays de la
région de fixer le cap et aux
partenaires dont nous sommes de les
soutenir la France prendra sa part mais
elle prendra sa part dans un cadre
collectif mesdames et messieurs les
députés avant de
conclure permettez-moi de réaffirmer
auut eff fort non seulement l'importance
des relations entre la France et les
pays africains mais surtout les moyens
que nous mettons au service de ces
ambitions à la suite des états généraux
de la diplomatie j'ai pris des mesures
pour renforcer le nombre de nos
personnels sur le continent dans nos
chancelleries dans nos services de
communication dans nos services d'action
culturel j'ai également voulu redonner
des moyens financiers aux ambassades via
le fond équipe France et via ce fond
d'appui à l'entrepreneur à
l'entrepreneuriat culturel le FAEC que
j'aiévoqué précédemment efficace pour
permettre à nos ambassades de mener sur
place des projets visibles rapides
important pour nos publics prioritaires
j'ai également pris des mesures pour
valoriser la filière africaniste auok
d'orsé avec désormais un concours dédié
et de nouvelles langues proposées à ce
concours le PUL le aousa le mandigay le
wallof et nous nous efforçons aussi de
diversifier davantage le recrutement de
mon ministère et d'attirer plus de
talent issus notamment de mon not
diaspora et enfin c'est avec
permettez-moi de terminer par les agents
qui nous
c'est avec un sentiment de profonde
reconnaissance à leur endroit que je
veux conclure il travaill parfois dans
des conditions difficiles dans des
conditions très difficiles quand nos
ambassades sont attaqué parfois
violemment comme ce fut le cas au
agagadouou ou à Niamé quand il s'agit
d'évacuer des civils sous le feu en
plein combat comme nous l'avons fait à
gartou dans ces moments de vérité dans C
moment de vérité lorsque l'engagement
professionnel implique pour nos agents
des questions de vie ou de mort car
c'est le cas ils ont toujours su faire
preuve d'un courage sans faille servir
servir leur pays servir nos compatriotes
et je rends hommage à leur dévouement un
dévouement à toute épreuve ce dévouement
qui fait honneur à la France je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Sébastien le ministre des
Armées madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale messieurs les
président de commission mesdames et
messieurs les députés je me réjouis à
mon tour d'avoir ce débat avec la
représentation nationale cet après-midi
à l'Assemblée ce soir au Sénat suite à
la demande formulée par plusieurs
groupes politiques ici présents il fait
écho ce débat à l'engagement pris par le
Président de la République devant les
présidents des deux chambres madame la
Présidente et les chefs de par réuni à
Saint- Nil 30 août dernier ce débat
permettra d'approfondir les fondamentaux
de notre coopération militaire avec nos
partenaires que je vais détailler dans
clarifier certains aspects si besoin en
étit mais au regard de ce que l'on peut
lire ici ou là le débat est nécessaire
et de faire un point sur leurs
évolutions à venir avant de revenir plus
précisément sur la situation sécuritaire
et par là même sur la question de la
présence militaire française sur le
continent africain je pense utile de
faire un court rappel historique et
politique du sens de cette présence sur
le continent africain il faut à la fois
distinguer la nature de nos engagements
militaires dont certains reposent sur
des accords de défense anciens tenir
compte des particularités qui
distinguent chaque pays où nos
militaires ont été engagés et bien sûr
comme toujours les menaces que nous
avons combattu et que nous devons demain
combattre on peut au fond distinguer
deux grandes périodes depuis le début
des années 2000 pour ne pas remonter
plus d'avant tout d'abord la période qui
va de 2000 à 2010 de nombreuses
interventions françaises ont été menées
dans le cadre de mission d'interposition
de maintien de la paix sous l'égite des
Nations Unies la plus connue étant sans
doute l'opération Licorne avec la
participation des forces armées
françaises au maintien de la paix en
Côte d'Ivoire ensuite pour la période
2010 à 2020 cette période a été marquée
par la lutte contre les groupes armés
terroristes à travers les opération cal
pu barcane au Sahel décidé
courageusement par le Président de la
République de l'époque François Hollande
et chaque fois la demande de nos
partenaires au Sahel ça a été rappelé
par la ministre cette menace demeure là
aussi nous y reviendrons dans un instant
on doit ensuite distinguer les
géographies des théâtres d'engagement il
n'y a pas une Afrique et c'est peut-être
là l'écueil du débat assez rapidement
que nous pourrons constater mais autant
de particularités qu'il y a d'État sur
ce continent on ne peut pas comparer la
lutte contre le terrorisme au Sahel avec
celle menée par exemple actuellement au
Mozambique dans le Cabo Delgado de la
même manière qu'on pas mettre sur le
même plan l'Afrique francophone
anglophone ou lusophone voire même les
différentes organisations régionales les
différences peuvent même être
infraétatiques mais je m'arrêterai là
pour ne pas être trop long il faut enfin
discerner les différents types de
menaces que nous avons à combattre ou
que nous avons combattu de la piraterie
et plus généralement des enjeux de
sécurité maritime dans le golfe de Guiné
ou bien encore dans le T3 babelmandel à
la lutte contre les trafics de tous
ordres le trafic d'êtres humains
le trafic de drogue ou d'armement en
passant par la menace terroriste qui
n'est pas sans lien sur le dernier point
que j'évoquais à l'instant que nous
combattons je ne reviens pas sur le
bilan de barce largement évoqué dans le
rapport des députés Tabarot et fux je
vous en remercie car tout le monde
s'accorde à dire désormais que le succès
militaire de l'opération n'est pas à
remettre en question j'ai envie de dire
enfin et nous avons su en tirer le
principal enseignement sur le plan
politique qui peut lui évidemment faire
débat qui est de ne pas se substituer à
l'action de nos partenaires et ou en
tout cas pas sur une période trop longue
de cela aussi nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir j'en suis sûr pendant le débat
parmi ces menaces celle qui est la plus
susceptible de toucher directement et de
déborder sur l'Europe et bien entendu si
j'ose dire la menace terroriste avec ses
effets dramatiques sur les populations
civiles ce qui peut poser un enjeu
migratoire ne nous leurons pas la
reconstitution progressive d'un
sanctuaire e au Sahel sur le modèle
jadis de l'Irak ou de la Syrie peut
faire peser à terme sur la région et
donc sur l'Europe les mêmes menaces
endogènes projetées ou inspirées que
nous avons connu ces dernières années à
partir d'autres théâtres mesdames et
messieurs les députés il est un principe
qui caractérise les missions de combat
de nos armées c'est l'intervention jadis
on aurait parlé de logique
expéditionnaire car elles n'ont par
nature pas vocation a resté durablement
sur un théâtre d'opération pour lequel
le partenaire ne fait pas ou ne fait
plus de la lutte contre le terrorisme
une priorité c'est pourquoi nos soldats
présents au Niger sont actuellement en
cours de rapatriement vers la France
nous aurons quitté ce pays avant la fin
de l'année comme le président de la
République l'a annoncé alors on peut
légitimement après coup s'interroger
aujourd'hui fallait-il répondre présent
lorsque nos partenaires africains nous
ont appelé à l'époque je serais
d'ailleurs curieux dans entendre les
positions de chaque sensibilité
politique qui s'est représenté à
l'Assemblée nationale pour ma part je
pense que oui car la France ne pouvait
laisser sans réponse l'appel à l'aide
des autorités autrefois légitimes de ces
pays exposés à un péril d'un terrorisme
islamique imminent pourquoi partir
aujourd'hui du Niger parce que la France
respecte la souveraineté des États
africains quelle que soit la direction
politique qu'il prennent même si nous ne
pouvons que le regretter là encore il ne
saurait y avoir de double standard
mesdames et messieurs les députés nos
objectifs sont clairs lutter contre la
menace terroriste islamiste garantir la
sécurité de nos ressortissants sur place
et approfondir nos partenariats
stratégiques d'intérêt commun comme cela
a été rappelé à l'instant par la
ministre des Affaires étrangères je sais
que ces objectifs sont aussi largement
partagé par la plupart des groupes
politiques puisqu'il figurent en grande
partie dans le rapport de Madame Tabarot
et de Monsieur fux que j'évoqué à
l'instant je tiens aussi à souligner les
travaux importants initiés par la
Commission de la Défense de l'Assemblée
nationale et son président Thomas
gassillou que je charge du regard avec
le cycle d'audition sur l'Afrique à la
fin duquel je me suis engagé monsieur le
Président à revenir devant la commission
au début d'année prochaine la
réarticulation entreprise depuis le
début de l'année vise à renforcer
l'attractivité de notre offre et la
solidité de nos partenariats avec les
États africains qui le souhaitent en
répondant aux grandes évolutions du
moment dans un environnement on le sait
beaucoup plus compétitif qu'auparavant
avant de vous présenter cette
réarticulation plus en détail je veux
vous présenter l'état actuel de notre
présence militaire sur le continent
africain nous avons au fond deux grandes
familles de forces de présence d'abord
deux pôles de coopération au Sénégal et
au Gabon ces bases ayant des éléments
prépositionnés depuis l'indépendance de
ces pays et la conclusion des premiers
traité de défense elles permettent
l'accès à des infrastructures qui
peuvent être utilisées à des fins
militaires et proposent de nombreuses
formations à ses partenaires ainsi qu'à
d'autres pays situés à proximité les
armements sur ces bases sont très
limités et servent essentiellement voire
exclusivement à la formation ensuite il
y a les bases militaires disposant de
capacités opérationnelles je pense aux
forces prépositionné en Côte d'Ivoire ou
à Djibouti la base d'Abidjan regroupe un
peu moins de 1000 militaires et celle de
Djibouti quasiment 1500 personnes qui se
sont notamment encore illustrés lors de
l'opération Sagittaire d'évacuation du
Soudan et qu'il me soit permis là aussi
de leur rendre hommage enfin le Tchad et
jusqu'à cet été au Niger nous avons des
bases de nature différentes nos forces
avaient vocation à agir sur demande et
en soutien des forces armées locales
dans le cadre d'opération
antiterroristes précises elles ont
contribué à freiner l'expansion de la
menace et permettait également de mener
des actions de coopération et de
formation des armées partenaires c'est
toujours le cas au Tchad ces capacités
de projection mesdames messieurs les
députés depuis l'hexagone sont par
ailleurs renforcé par la loi de
programmation militaire que vous avez
voté l'été dernier je n'y reviens pas
nous avions pris le temps de détailler
cet aspect Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires la la France est donc
présente au côté de ses partenaires
africains lorsqu'ils le souhaitent pour
mieux assurer leur propre sécurité et en
répondant à leurs demandes certains
d'entre eux comme la Côte d'Ivoire le
Sénégal le Bénin le Gabon par exemple et
il y en a d'autres ont accompli des
efforts remarquables dans la montée en
puissance de leurs appareils de sécurité
c'est vrai des services c'est vrai de
leurs forces armées et ont obtenu de
belles victoires sur le terrain face aux
groupes armés terroristes par ailleurs
et c'est un point central nous faisons
évoluer notre accompagnement le
renforçant sur le plan de nos offres de
formation
sur le plan capacitaire et sur le plan
notre réseau diplomatique de défense
vous me permettrez d'en dire un mot pour
chacun des points en matière de
formation tout d'abord nos efforts ont
ainsi porté sur nos capacités d'accueil
en Afrique au sein de nos écoles
militaires françaises avec l'objectif de
doubler les places de formation à la
rentrée 2023 nous comptons déjà une
centaine de places supplémentaires d'ors
et déjà attribué à des sous-officiers et
officiers africains je tiens également à
souligner qu'en 2022 près de 3000
stagiaires africains sont passés par
notre réseau d'école nationale à
vocation régionale à l'appuie de cette
dynamique 25000 militaires africains ont
été formés sur le continent depuis le
début de l'année 10000 militaires
français et africains suivent des
entraînements conjoints pour se former
ensemble au défi sécuritaire
d'aujourd'hui et de demain cela pourrait
paraître anecdotique mais nous
poursuivrons ces missions communes
surtout pour tourner la page des
réduction de ses capacités
malheureusement engagé depuis la moitié
des années 90 et dont nous mettons enfin
un frein et un terme sur le plan
capacitaire ensuite je veux insister sur
notre volonté de mobiliser davantage nos
industriels et équipementti je suis
revenu devant la commission de la
défense il y a peu de temps afin de
fournir un accompagnement capacitaire
moderne mais adapté au besoins de nos
partenaires africains c'est vrai pour le
prix c'est vrai pour la nature des
équipements sans oublier les sauts
technologiques attendus en matière de
drone ou de cyber sur lequel les
attentes sont aussi très importantes le
délégué général pour l'armement s'est
rendu à ma demande sur le continent une
première depuis 1960 1 ce qui dit tout
de la relation aussi militaire sur le
terrain capacitaire entre les différents
pays d'Afrique et la France et donc on
voit bien que là l'axe de progrès est à
faire et les équipes pour l'Afrique de
la DGA ont été renforcé largement à cet
effet sur le plan de la diplomatie de
défense enfin notre réseau en Afrique se
densifie et je le dis devant la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
avec l'ouverture de nouveaux postes
d'attachés de défense le Rwanda à l'été
2022 les Comores Guiné Bissau cet été un
attaché d'armement au Sénégal et en RCI
dans quelques mois bref là aussi un axe
d'effort est important pour reconstituer
des capacités de conseillers militaires
pour nos ambassadeurs mais également
d'être en lien avec les forces armées
locales puisque comme vous le savez la
disparition du service national dans
dans les années 90 ont conduit à fermer
un certain nombre de postes de
coopérants sans qu'il ne soit forcément
compensé par des augmentations de moyens
sur les missions de défense et là aussi
c'est un point attendu par les
différents partenaires pour conclure
Madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale au-delà ses principaux axes
d'effort le volet renseignement est
également un axe essentiel que je ne
peux développer ici dans le détail mais
j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire devant la
représentation nationale lors d'une
audition devant la délégation
parlementaire pour le renseignement avec
le directeur général de la sécurité
extérieure nous prendrons également soin
de continuer à engager nos alliés en
Afrique en associant plus encore nos
partenaires européens et américains à
ces missions comme la ministre l'a
évoqué précédemment enfin et j'en
terminerai euh la France et nos
partenaires africains sont liés par un
honneur commun au combat et une
singulière histoire partagée que nous
avons à cœur de faire vivre nous ouvrons
une période mémorielle importante qui
mettra à l'honneur l'action de l'armée
d'Afrique tout au long des
commémorations de la Libération avec en
2023 2024 le 80e anniversaire de sa
participation à la libération de la
Corse à la campagne d'Italie et bien sûr
au débarquement de Provence je veis
ainsi conclure en rendant hommage à ces
combattants d'Afrique tombés sous les
couleurs de la France et pour la liberté
au côté de leurs frères d'armes comme je
pense également à nos soldats morts au
Sael ainsi qu'à nos blessés et à leur
familles je vous remercie merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Michelle
Tabarot pour une dirée de 10 minutes
pour les
[Applaudissements]
républicains
madame la présidente madame la ministre
des Affaires étrangères monsieur le
ministre des Armées messieurs les
présidents de commission mesdames
messieurs la représentation nationale
peut enfin échanger avec vous sur la
stratégie africaine de la France et j'en
suis heureuse parce que nous avons
beaucoup à apporter à ce débat nous
l'avons démontré et encore récemment
avec la présentation du rapport
d'information sur les relations entre la
France et l'Afrique que nous avons rendu
avec notre collègue Bruno fou ce
document a été bien accueilli et va
nourrir de nombreuses réflexions dans
notre commission des affaires étrangères
je regrette d'ailleurs que le groupe
renaissant soit le seul à s'être abstenu
sur la publication de ce de ce rapport
tous les autres groupes ont soutenu ce
travail parce qu'ils ont compris qu'il
posaient un état des lieux sincère et
objectif sur les causes de notre perte
d'influence
nous y montrons les erreurs de la France
depuis bien avant 2017 d'ailleurs il y a
eu des comportements mal perçus et des
attitudes vexatoires nous avons aussi
affaibli ce qui fonctionnait bien dans
notre relation notre réseau culturel et
éducatifs nos coopérations les moyens de
nos ambassades mais ce rapport parle
aussi de nos réussites car bien sûr il y
en a et nous les saluons sans
arrière-penser c'est le cas par exemple
de l'ouverture vers l'autre Afrique
lusophone anglophone qu'il faut
poursuivre et amplifier nous pointons
également les sujets de tension comme la
forme des visas qu'il faut engager
rapidement sans renoncer à la maîtrise
des flux à l'impératif de lutte contre
l'immigration illégale et nous dénonçons
enfin le comportement déloyal de
certains de nos concurrents à l'image
des Russes et des jeintes dont nous
sommes devenus les Bou émissaire ainsi
vous le voyez ce n'est pas un document à
charge c'est un constat sur une
situation
difficile accompagné de recommandations
pour réinventer notre relation avec
l'Afrique sur ce sujet le chef de l'État
multiplié les déclarations ces derniers
mois en novembre 2022 à Toulon quand il
a parlé de la revue nationale
stratégique en février à l'Élysée dans
son discours sur la politique africaine
et en mars en clôture des états généraux
de la diplomatie à chaque fois c'est la
promesse d'une nouvelle approche de
partenariat renouvelés d'une diplomatie
d'un influence enfin assumé et avec des
moyens mais au-delà des mots il ne se
passe pas
grand-chose bien sûr je sais l'ampleur
de la tâche et l'engagement de notre
diplomatie et de nos armées sur ces
questions mais que de temps perdu depuis
le pécher originel du discours de
ouagadougu qui prétendait tout
réinventer et qui disons le clairement a
échoué le président y a annoncé la fin
de la politique africaine de la France
quelle erreur parce que le résultat est
là cela fait 6 ans qu'il essaie de
recoller les morceaux il a compris bien
trop tard que la France a besoin d'une
politique africaine comme toutes les
grandes puissances qui ont une stratégie
pour ce continent d'avenir avec chez
certains une approche bien plus
agressive et bien moins éthique que la
nôtre je pense à la Chine sur le plan
économique à la Turquie sur le plan
culturel et religieux à la Russie sur le
plan
sécuritaire face à eux l'offre de la
France ne peut pas se limiter au champs
privilégé par le chef de l'État comme le
sport ou la culture ce n'est pas
l'attente fondamentale des pays
africains voilà pourquoi la France doit
avoir une vraie stratégie d'influence et
qu'elle doit surtout l'assumer à force
de se taire nos int à force de taire nos
intentions on laisse libre cours à
toutes les théories du complot qui font
tellement de mal
aujourd'hui oui il nous faut une
nouvelle stratégie mais pour moi elle ne
peut plus être le fait d'un seul homme
j'ai critiqué leserement de notre
politique étrangère élaborée en vasclos
et hypercentralisé ça a d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'éplu à certains et pourtant
c'est exactement ce que nous avons vu au
Proche Orient avec les annonces
improvisées du chef de l'État qui ont
surpris surpris tout le monde y compris
vous y compris nos alliés au final le
président a dû faire machine àrière
c'est catastrophique pour l'image de la
France alors je le dis sans détour il
faut aérer la politique étrangère il
faut ouvrir le domaine réservé pour en
faire un domaine partagé et le Parlement
y a toute sa place comme nous le
démontrons comme le démontrent les
échanges de ce jour nous avons une
vision et nous avons des
propositions notre rapport à la
politique étrangère pourrait être bien
plus important alors puisque nous
parlons des nouveaux partenariats avec
l'Afrique le groupe les républicains est
convaincu qu'il faut mener de profondes
réformes pour renforcer les synergies
l'ensemble des acteurs doit désormais
agir au service de notre diplomatie
d'influence cela paraît évident et
pourtant concernant la France ce sera
une vraie révolution parce
qu'aujourd'hui ces connexions se font
trop peu voilà pourquoi nous voulons une
réforme de l'AFD il faut lui redonner un
véritable pilotage politique comme le
réclame la Cour des comptes il faut
aussi que son action soit visible ce
n'est plus possible que la France
soutienne des projets mais que son
action ne soit ni reconnue ni valorisée
quel autre pays accepterait-il
cela nous nous voulons aussi que nos
ambassadeurs aient plus de moyens pour
soutenir des projets qui touchent
directement les populations à l'image de
ce que font d'autres
représentations puisque je parle de nos
ambassadeurs ils doivent retrouver un
rôle central ils doivent devenir les
véritables chefs de fil de l'équipe de
France à l'étranger il faut aussi mieux
les préparer inspirons-nous des
États-Unis qui forment leurs diplomates
pendant des semaines avant de les
envoyer en Afrique j'en viens à notre
offre stratégique et
militaire je tiens à redire que la
présence française n'a jamais été imposé
nous sommes dans les pays qui le
souhaitent sur la base de partenariats
renforcés effectivement ils doivent être
rénovés parce que nous sommes dans une
compétition acharnée face à des
concurrents qui n'ont pas toujours les
mêmes valeurs que nous le ministère des
armées travaille et identifier monsieur
le ministre vous nous l'avez confirmé
les attentes de nos partenaires c'est
une démarche clé pour adapter notre
catalogue
elle doit se doubler d'une vraie
réflexion sur l'offre de notre BITD face
à la concurrence de matériel bon marché
par exemple venu de Turquie j'espère que
nous pourrons en reparler bientôt parce
que là aussi c'est un élément majeur de
notre présence sur ce continent je
pourrais évoquer bien d'autres sujets la
coopération technique scientifique
humanitaire et cette erreur fondamentale
de la diminution sensible du nombre de
coopérants sur le terrain notre réseau
culturel et la diminution du nombre de
nos écoles en Afrique l'affaiblissement
de la Francophonie qui est pourtant un
atout considérable et aussi la nécessité
de développer des écosystèmes favorable
à l'implantation des entreprises
françaises notamment dans des pays où
nous avons de vrais po de développement
mais pour en terminer avec ces
propositions je voudrais en venir à
notre
communication parce que la capacité à
valoriser nos actions et à répondre aux
attaques c'est le corelaire
indispensable de toute stratégie
d'influence nous le voyons
particulièrement s'agissant du continent
africain nos ambassades et nos services
doivent avoir des moyens pour mieux
communiquer et mieux lutter contre la
désinformation quant à nos médias
publics ils ne peuvent pas relayer à
longueur de journée des messages haineux
contre la France sans montrer également
d'autres points de vue ils sont libres
de décider leur ligne éditoriale mais
ils doivent avoir conscience qu'en
Afrique ils sont vus comme des médias
d'État à travers eux c'est la voix de la
France qui est perçue les Africains
eux-mêmes nous ont dit ne pas comprendre
pourquoi nos propres médias ne parlent
pas mieux de notre pays alors j'en
appelle à leur responsabilité ils
doivent s'attacher à valoriser les
actions de la France parce qu'ils sont
essentiels à notre
image madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre nous portons ainsi la vision
d'une diplomatie d'influence assumée
regroupant l'ensemble des acteurs autour
des intérêts de la France et de nos
partenaires cette vision rejoint en
partie celle du chef de l'État mais
encore une fois des paroles aux actes le
chemin est long la commission des
affaires étrangères va poursuivre ses
travaux commission de la défense vient
de lancer un cycle d'audition sur
l'Afrique le groupe les républicains est
déterminé à travailler à cette
refondation il y a une fenêtre
d'opportunité unique pour construire
ensemble la nouvelle stratégie africaine
de la France alors j'espère que vous
nous écouterez j'espère que vous
respecterez nos travaux et j'espère que
nous serons durablement associés à ce
projet parce qu'il est essentiel au
rayonnement de notre pays il est
essentiel pour la place la France doit
retrouver dans le monde merci merci
beaucoup mes chers
collègues la parole est à Madame
jeunevève Darie pour le groupe démocrate
pour une durée de 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur ministre messieurs les
présidents de commission chers collègues
alors au nom du groupe démocrate d'abord
je tiens à remercier le gouvernement et
et vous ministre ici présent pour cette
déclaration qui permet le débat autour
des partenariats entre France et pays
africains alors oui nos partenariats
avec l'Afrique sont anciens forts et en
constante évolution nous devons sans
cesse les adapter à l'évolution des
besoins exprimés par les pays africains
et certainement mieux les valoriser je
mettrai l'accent sur la stratégie de
défense de notre pays et notre souhait
de mener de nouveaux partenariat
militaire avec les pays africains depuis
2017 la France a fait entrer une
nouvelle grille de lecture dans ses
relations avec l'Afrique et souhait
inscrire de manière pérenne des rapports
de réciprocité harmonieux et responsable
et ceci alors que l'influence de
certaines puissances étrangères se fait
de plus en plus prégnante
nous devons adopter une posture
équilibrée et bâtir un nouveau modèle de
partenariat militaire cela commence
d'abord par notre manière notre présence
la façon dont nous sommes présents sur
place par l'expression claire de nos
objectifs et surtout par la façon de
nous avons de répondre toujours mieux à
la demande des pays demande légitime
d'africanisation de monter en compétence
et d'autonomie de leurs armées et de
leur force de sécurité plusieurs pistes
doivent être poursuivies et bien sûr
nous devons développer et augmenter
l'offre de formation d'accompagnement et
d'équipement vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre pour atteindre un niveau
supérieur et ceci engage nos armées mais
également notre industrie de défense
nous devons rester vigilants au combat
de la communication qui se joue sur
place et à l'impact que cela peut avoir
sur les actions menées par la France
les crises de ces derniers mois au Mali
au Burkina Faso et au Niger en sont
l'exemple parfait la France a fait
l'objet d'un rejet massif de la classe
politique locale elle est devenue le
bouc émissaire idéal pour reprendre les
mots du président de la République et
les campagnes de déstabilisation qui ont
été menées ont porté leur fruit dehors
la France pouvait-on lire et par effet
dominau la présence militaire en France
a été remise en cause dans ces pays qui
nous avait appelé et qui avait demandé
notre soutien dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme alors nous ne sommes pas
naïfs sur le rôle joué par les
ingérences russes en Afrique et dans les
médias depuis 10 ans la Russie a
méthodiquement déployé une stratégie
globale sur le continent africain dans
tous les domaines influence politique
communication sécurité fourniture
d'armes ce constat suppose que nous
devons évoluer dans notre manière de
communiquer sur nos actions
sur les dispositifs que nous déployons
il faut apporter de la cohérence de la
lisibilité de la compréhension par les
populations et nous devons être à
l'initiative mais pas seulement en
position défensive avec ce changement de
paradigme la France doit s'appuyer sur
ses partenaires fiables et c'est le cas
vous les avez cité monsieur le ministre
notamment de la Mauritanie du Sénégal du
Bénin de la Côte d'Ivoire en effet nos
relations par exemple avec la Mauritanie
sont stables dans de nombreux domaines
et même s'accélèreent la coopération est
importante en terme de sécurité et de
défense dans le but de renforcer
l'expertise mauritanienne dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et les trafics nous
pouvons également saluer la durabilité
de nos liens avec le Sénégal autour de
formations nombreuses donné avec les
éléments français du Sénégal et ses
accords de coopération militaire
bilatéral sont la preuve d'un travail de
en bonne intelligence entre la France et
le Sénégal et puis des relations
nouvelles avec le Bénin qui s'intensifie
par exemple où nous avons pu avec l'acte
symbolique de restitution d'une
collection d'objets au Musée historique
de Cotonou en 2021 et bien développer
une coopération et surtout une confiance
un contexte de confiance favorable à
cette coopération alors apportons un
regard positif sur ce qui fonctionne
mettons euh en avant les réussites et ne
fermons pas les yeux sur les critiques
et sur nos échecs adaptons-nous soyons
réalistes et je crois que c'est ainsi
que nous pourrons aider l'Afrique euh et
les pays africains à apporter des
solutions que euh ces pays attendent de
notre part et je dois dire que les
écoles dont vous avez parlé monsieur le
ministre sont un exemple important
l'école nationale de cybersécurité à
vocation régionale à
notre et puis l'Académie internationale
de lutte contre le terrorisme en Côte
d'Ivoire est un nouvel exemple ils sont
nombreux alors oui la France doit
continuer de construire des coopérations
nouvelles solides et durables avec les
pays africains d'égal à égal avec eux
cultivant ainsi la confiance et le
respect mutuel je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma cher collègue la parole est
pour le groupe socialiste à Madame Anna
pic pour une durée de 10 minutes
merci merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les
ministres la nouvelle donne africaine
ainsi aurions-nous pu qualifier le débat
qui nous anime aujourd'hui militairement
politiquement économiquement une page
historique de la relation de la France à
l'Afrique semble s'être définitivement
tourné le coup d'État au Niger en
juillet dernier et le retrait forcé de
nos forces armées depuis lors nous
oblige à porter en acte le débat
récurrent de la reconfiguration de nos
relations en 2013 la France lancé
l'opération cal François Hollande était
acclamé et accueilli en libérateur au
Mali 10 ans plus tard la présence
française au Sahel et ailleurs en
Afrique est dénoncée d'une intervention
sollicitée à une présence contester
comment en sommes-nous arrivés là les
sociétés africaines se sont transformées
sous l'effet d'une démographie dynamique
faisant de ce continent l'un des plus
jeunes dont le poids dans la population
mondiale est de plus en plus important
mais aussi sous l'effet de la
numérisation de la démocratisation de
l'accès au savoir et à la culture et de
l'accès à la connaissance de l'évolution
des relations internationales la
nouvelle donne africaine c'est aussi
l'histoire d'une mondialisation de
l'Afrique dont nous avons tardé à
prendre pleinement conscience depuis
plus de 10 ans la présence militaire
française en Afrique semble avoir masqué
l'érosion progressive de son influence
politique et économique j'en veux pour
preuve deux illustrations en l'espace de
3 ans Mali Burkina Faso et Niger avec
lesquels nous entretenions de bonnes
relations ont connu des coups d'État sur
fond de défiance à l'égard de la France
au point de réclamer le départ de nos
forces armées et de nos diplomates alors
que les pars de marché de la France en
Afrique représentaient 10,2 % en 2001
elle ne représentait plus que 4,1 % en
2021 à titre de comparaison l'Allemagne
ou encore la Turquie nous ont dépassé la
Chine quant à elle caracole en tête avec
18 % au point que l'on parle d'orénav
d'orénavant de Chine-Afrique au cœur du
mécontentement qui explique cet
affaiblissement une jeunesse trop
souvent plongée dans une extrême
pauvreté tourmentée par des enjeux
sécuritair illustré par le djihadisme et
dont les aspirations ne sont pas
sérieusement prises en compte en résulte
une urgences de la ranqueœur Coloniale
une profonde incompréhension quant à
l'incapacité française à permettre le
développement économique et social des
états et à éliminer la perpétuelle
menace djihadiste ce déclin de l'image
de la France a ouvert la voie à une
mondialisation teintée d'opportunisme de
l'Afrique dont la jeunesse est une des
clés de compréhension et dont la France
a tardé à prendre pleinement conscience
Chine États-Unis Russie Inde Japon
Allemagne ou encore Turquie sont
désormais bien implantés militairement
ou économiquement parfois les deux sur
le continent africain dès lors et dès
2013 et alors que la France les
États-Unis et l'Angleterre s'interrogent
sur une possible intervention en Syrie
en réponse aux attaques de Bachar
el-Assad avec des armes illégales sur sa
population Vladimir Poutine prend la
parole à l'ONU et proclame et se
proclame le garant de la stabilité
contre le chaos provoqué par l'Occident
et son idéologie la Russie s'attache
alors à renforcer son influence et en
particulier sur non sur le continent
africain la France est-elle able à est
seul de son affaiblissement non
évidemment avons-nous toujours agi sans
commettre la moindre erreur la réponse
est identique et tout aussi évidente
pour explorer les conditions de
partenariat français renouvelé avec les
pays africains reconnaissons en premier
lieu les erreurs que nous avons commise
je ne sais pas si l'opération barce est
un échec ou si elle n'a pas marché mais
je sais néanmoins qu'en matière
d'antiterrorisme une intervention
militaire ne constitue pas une politique
en soi la victoire militaire de
l'opération cal au Mali n'affaibli pas
le djihadisme si certains chefs ont été
éliminés le rôle politique et économique
de ces acteurs dans un tissu local a été
sous-estimé l'approche sécuritaire n'a
pas eu l'effet politique escompté celui
que nous attendions fléo de l'esprit
traduit en acte barbare inqualifiable
nous devons lutter de manière intangible
contre le terrorisme et ce qu'il
représente je tiens d'ailleurs à
souligner le courage de nos forces
armées et j'ai une pensé pour les 58
soldats ayant perdu la vie au cours des
opérations Cal et barcane leur
engagement était à la fois sincère et
disons-le nécessaire nous leur en serons
à jamais reconnaissants mais les groupes
djihadistes sont des acteurs politiques
à part entière et la première étape pour
les vaincre sera de les considérer comme
telles pour établir notre stratégie
reconnaître nos erreurs passera
également par le fait de ne plus
regarder l'Afrique comme un tout
indifférencié considérer ces états comme
de véritables partenaires ta tel devra
être notre feuille de route ainsi et
quel que soit la nature de nos futurs
partenariats nous devrons apporter toute
la considération qu'il mérite à ces pays
dans le respect de leur particularisme
et vous l'avez dit Madame la Ministre et
en admettant que nos enjeux nos
objectifs et nos priorités ne soient pas
nécessairement les leurs à cet Agard C
ces partenariats ne pourront faire fi de
la façon dont les états envisagent
structurellement leurs relations avec
les autres forces régional et
international y compris nos compétiteurs
nous devrons ensuite prendre garde à ne
pas surestimer les stratégies de
désinformations sans les sous-estimer
non plus de certaines puissances
étrangères si elles sont avérées aucun
des chercheurs que nous avons pu
auditionner ne confirme l'existence d'un
sentiment antifrançais celui-ci relevant
plutôt d'une facilité langagière pour
imaginer imager les fake news populistes
et complotties qui fleurissent et qui
inondent les réseaux sociaux et si la
colère d'une partie des Africains est
renforcée par les politiques de
désinformation des trolls numériques de
ces pays la maîtrise aléatoire de la
communication de la France et de son
président en a facilité l'influence fort
heureusement un champ des possibles
s'offre à nous pour améliorer nos
relations avec le continent africain et
ses nombreux pays le premier aspect est
structurant sans verser dans une
autoflagélation abandonnons notre hibrce
gaulien et admettons que le monde dans
lequel notre action s'inscrit a
profondément changé la France n'est plus
la puissance qu'elle était acceptons-le
faisons preuve d'humilité et admettons
ne plus avoir l'influence d' d'autant
acceptons-le pour mieux rebondir
réapparaître comme un partenaire fiable
vis-à-vis de nos alliés en d'autres
termes changeons de regard sur
nous-mêmes pour changer de regard sur
les autres abandonnons notre ton Pat
analy symbole de la francearique et
héritage une colonisation dont nous
devons définitivement faire table rase
abandonnons également la notion de
domaine réservé du chef de l'État qui ne
relève que de la pratique et n'a rien de
constitutionnellement évident notamment
dans la répartition des prérogatives
entre l'Élysée et Matignon dans cette
optique la France gagnerait à travailler
une décentralisation décisionnelle en
matière de politique étrangère comment
décemment admettre au nom d'une
efficacité toute relative que seul une
poignée de personne soit habilité à
prendre en cercle restreint des décision
d'une telle ampleur depuis 2013 le
Parlement n'a discuté de l'intervention
militaire au Sahel que deux fois deux
fois en 10 ans la parlementarisation du
processus décisionnel en matière de
politique étrangère aarît indispensable
la décentralisation que nous appelons de
nos vux passera également par le
développement de la coopération
décentralisée qui renforce les échanges
locaux autant que les communautés alors
que les États sont parfois inexistants
le dernier P de ce travail de
décentralisation correspond davantage à
un rééquilibre et apparaît comme une
évidence remettre le quai d'orsé dans
les dont les compétences sont
incomparables au cœur de notre politique
étrangère enfin le dernier point de ce
champ des possible passera par la
redéfinition de notre aide au
développement et par la fin des
politiques vexatoires en matière de visa
des décisions salutaires ont été prises
en effet y compris sur les visas je
pense notamment aussi à la restitution
des objets d'art et de cultures
africains à la reconnaissance de la
responsabilité du colonialisme français
ou la reconnaissance du génocide rondé
nous devons cependant reconsidérer notre
politique d'aide par l'emprunt laquelle
ne peut plus être le soc de notre aide
au développement quand la Chine ou les
États du gooff n'ont pas ce type
d'exigence financière et en profitent
pour accroître leur implantation qu'elle
soit économique ou autre sur le
continent africain ces évolutions
devront également s'accompagner d'une
véritable stratégie visant à refaire de
la sphère francophone un espace
d'échange de savoir de culture et de
connaissance facilité et en finir avec
une politique des visas qui est une
véritable épine dans le pied pour la
France avec le retrait de nos forces au
Sahel nos rapports avec les pays
africains sont amenés à définitivement
changer pour autant cela ne signifie pas
que nous devons passer de
l'interventionnisme à l'abandon la
redéfinition de nos partenariat devra
répondre à un certain nombre de défis
celui de la cohérence car pratiquer la
réale politique ne doit pas nous
empêcher de soutenir en Afrique comme
ailleurs les valeurs que nous prenons en
Europe celui du respect des
particularismes pour ne pas reproduire
les erreurs du passé celui de
l'ouverture sur le monde en profitant
pleinement de la Francophonie pour
restaurer notre image et nos relations
bien sûr ne disposant que de 10 minutes
j'ai dû faire des choix qui ne permet
pas de débattre de manière approfondie
et différenciée de l'ensemble des enjeux
de nos relations à ce continent je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma cher collègue
la parole est à Madame Anne leenf pour
le groupe
[Applaudissements]
horizon
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères chers collègues si
tu veux aller vite marche seul mais si
tu veux aller loin marchons ensemble
dans cette phrase se trouve tout
l'esprit de notre ambition pour le
continent
africain mais pour cela pour débattre
comme nous le faisons aujourd'hui dans
de nos relations avec les pays africains
nous devons garder en mémoire deux
vérités essentielles ci d'abord que ces
relations ne peuvent se construire dans
la caricature et ensuite que les
réponses au défis du 21e siècle ne
doivent pas émaner de la France et des
Européens mais être construites sur une
logique de partenariat renouvelé sortir
de la caricature d'abord c'est arrêter
de considérer le continent africain s le
seul prisme sécuritaire et je le dis en
tant que membre de la commission de la
défense les coups d'État qui ont
gangriné le Sahel ces dernières années
ne doivent pas nous aveugler sur la
richesse
et la diversité de ce continent où comme
le président de la République le
rappelait en 2017 à wagadouu se joue une
partie de notre avenir
commun mais aussi parce que trop souvent
les contevérités s'accumulent d'cun
voudrait remettre en cause la légitimité
ou l'efficacité de nos opérations au
Sahel disons-le clairement nos soldats
ont lutté contre la menace djihadiste à
la demande des États africains n nos
soldats y ont au côté des militaires des
armées africaines et au péril de leur
vie remporté
des victoires contre des groupes armés
djihadistes au Sahel aussi je veux
rendre hommage au nom du groupe horizon
et apparenté au soldats aux blessés et à
ceux qui ont perdu la vie ainsi qu'à
leur famille sortir des caricatures
c'est aussi garder en tête la diversité
des pays africains il n'y a pas une mais
de nombreuses Afriques la France
entretient des liens avec chacun des 54
pays du continent dans le cadre de
relations bilatérales tout tous ces pays
ont leur spécificité ce n'est qu'en
refusant de réduire les relations
franco-africaines à une seule situation
que nous pourrons poser les bases saines
pour des partenariats renouvelés avec
les pays africains cette logique de
partenariat a été clairement définie par
le Président de la République le 27
février dernier il s'agit en effet du
sortir d'une logique alliant uniquement
l'approche sécuritaire et l'aide au
développement imposé par les Français ou
les Européens pour investir la
coopération économique et culturell dans
des projets favorables à la prospérité
du
continent la politique étrangère de la
France en Afrique consiste à mettre fin
à la logique de
l'évidence pour avancer ensemble main
dans la main en véritable partenaire
nous avons pour cela de nombreux atouts
qu'il nous faut faire valoir il nous
faut construire une nouvelle relation
équilibrée réciproque et responsable
avec avec les pays africains les
domaines dans lesquels la coopération
entre la France et les pays africains
peut-être renforcé sont nombreux il
concerne la santé la culture le sport
l'entrepreneuriat les États africains
sont des terres d'optimisme et de
volontarisme qui doivent mutuellement
qui doivent actuellement faire face à
une situation sans précédent compte tenu
du nombre de défis à relever en même
temps climatique démographique sanitaire
éducatif économique sécuritaire autant
de défis auxquels la France doit
également répondre pour cela nous avons
plusieurs leviers et atout que nous
devons savoir mettre en avant la langue
française que nous partageons avec
l'Afrique francophone le million de
Français de la Réunion et de Mayotte qui
vivent en Afrique et dont nous voulons
renforcer l'intégration régionale nos
diaspora aussi bien les Français qui
vivent en Afrique que les Africains qui
vivent en France le roupe Horizon est
parenté estime que nous pouvons
développer une stratégie reposant sur
trois piliers la lutte contre le
changement climatique la jeunesse et la
démocratie sur le changement climatique
d'abord le continent africain peut
devenir un acteur majeur de la réduction
des émissions de carbone il n'est
responsable finalement que de 10 % des
émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre les États africains peuvent se
développer rapidement sans répéter les
erreurs d'un siècle de développement
occidental fondé sur les énergies
fossiles le sommet one forest Summit
organisé au Gabon le 1er et 2 mars 2023
à l'initiative des présidents gabonais
et français a été l'occasion de rappeler
l'importance des forêts tropicales
africaines puis de carbone à préserver
l'enjeu climatique est d'autant plus
pressant pour un continent davantage
confronté que d'autres à la pression du
changement climatique un enjeu de taille
au vu des événements météorologiques
extrêmes qui peuvent empirer
l'insécurité alimentaire les
déplacements de population et les
conflits du fait de son dynamisme
démographique le continent africain est
le plus jeune du monde et par conséquent
l'accompagnement de la jeunesse est un
enjeu majeur la France souhaite
continuer son implication au côté des
états demandeur aussi bien dans la
construction d'établissements scolaires
dans la diversification des offres de
formation professionnelle que les
échanges scolaires et l'orientation à ce
titre je rappelle que les universités
françaises ont le plaisir d'accueillir
un nombre toujours croissant d'étudiants
africains 150000 en 2021 soit 40 % de
plus qu'en 2017 enfin face à la
recréescence des coups d'état depuis
2020 la France peut porter au plus haut
l'intérêt démocratique loin d'imposer et
de proclamer ses valeurs elle a la
possibilité de contribuer à ce que des
réseaux d'intellectuels et d'acteurs
civils fassent vivre la démocratie au
niveau local au lendemain du sommet
afrique-fance de montpelli en 2021
réunissant les acteurs de la société
civile française et Afrique
une fondation sur l'innovation et la
démocratie a été lancée à
Johannesbourg par notre proximité notre
histoire commune et notre amitié nous
entretenons un lien unique avec les
États africains ce lien doit nous
inspirer dans la relation que nous
voulons développé notamment à travers
les partenariats renouvelés réciproques
et équilibrés respectant les intérêts de
chacun c'est une autre voie que nous
devons poursuivre une voie qui ne
réduise pas l'Afrique à un terrain de
compétition ou de rente mais qui
considère les pays africains comme des
partenaires avec qui nous avons des
intérêts et des responsabilités
partagées unis autour de cet envie
d'Afrique ainsi dans le domaine
économique et financier la France a
entamé avec ses partenaires en 2019 la
réforme du Fran CFA en supprimant
l'obligation de centralisation des
réserves de change sur le compte
d'opération au Trésor français en se
retirant des instances de gouvernance de
la zone monétaire dans le domaine de la
santé la France a soutenu l'excellence
scientifique africaine comme celle du
Centre de Crise africain celle de
l'Institut Pasteur de Dakar et celle de
l'Institut national de recherche
biologique du professeur muyembe elle
participe à la communauté internationale
au développement de centes de production
de vaccins sur le continent africain
dans le domaine de la culture la France
a lancé un premier forum sur les
industries culturelles et cré et
créatives africaines en octobre 2023
avec pour objectif de reconnecter le
regard des Français avec la création
contemporaine africaine dans toutes ses
composantes les instituts français
l'Alliance française et les réseaux de
coopération accueillent et promuvent les
œuvres des artistes africains enfin dans
la continuité de plusieurs textes
adoptés sous la précédente législature
une loi cadre sera proposée
prochainement sur les restitutions
d'œuvr d'art aux pays africains qui le
demandent la déclaration de Madame et
messieurs les ministres devant notre
assemblée n'est pas un hasard les
parlementaires que nous sommes avont je
le pense un rôle à jouer dans cette
nouvelle relation avec les pays africain
au-delà des groupes d'amitié dans
lesquels nous sommes nombreux à être
présents la création d'un groupe de
travail Afrique au sein de la commission
de la défense et des Affaires étrangères
ainsi que les réceptions de délégations
africaines font partie de la diplomatie
parlementaire très grandement apprécié
par nos partenaires et qui nous
apprennent mutuellement beaucoup enfin
ces défis communs ne se limite pas à des
relations
franco-africaines mais s'étend à
l'ensemble des pays européens que ce
soit par des accords politiques ou une
révision de la logique d'aide au
développement telle qu'annoncé par le
Président de la République nous devons
nous appuyer les uns sur les autres
collectivement afin de renouveler nos
partenariats plutôt qu'agir seul c'est
fort de ce dialogue démocratique et
européen que nous pourrons j'en suis
convaincu saisir au mieux les
opportunités pour transformer
efficacement nos partenariats et nos
compréhensions mutuelles avec les pays
du continent africain
alors seulement nous pourrons marcher
ensemble vers un horizon commun je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma ch
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien Tach pour le groupe écologiste
pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
monsieur le Président bourlange chers
collègues je me réjouis que nous
puissions aujourd'hui nous retrouver
dans cet hémicycle pour débattre de la
fonte des relations franco-africaines
des relations qu'entretient la France
avec un certain nombre de pays d'Afrique
d'ailleurs comme le titre de ces débat
nous y invite puisquévoquer une relation
entre entre notre pays et un continent
qui représente 20 % de la surface
terrestre et de la population mondiale
n'aurait évidemment pas de sens j'en
profite pour saluer les membres de la
délégation mauritanienne que j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir cette semaine dans
le cadre du groupe d'amitié qui lit les
députés de nos deux pays et qui nous
font l'honneur d'assister à ce débat
ainsi que mon collègue du groupe
écologiste Karim bencher député des
Français d'Afrique de l'Ouest et du Nord
cette précision est établi ses
salutations faites il était grand temps
qu'un tel débat intervienne au Parlement
et que les représentants de la nation se
saisissent pleinement de ce sujet notre
politique extérieure objet du précaré
élyséen comme l'Afrique francophone
aurait été celui de la France à une
époque ne peut plus s'exprimer à travers
la seule voix du président de la
République et de ses ministres d'autant
qu'au fil des discrédit et des impères
la voix du président de la République a
aujourd'hui grandement perdu de sa
crédibilité sur la scène internationale
et représente dès lors en Afrique le
visage d'une France sans boussole il est
donc grand temps d'en finir avec ces
vieilles lunes et ce débat est en ce
sens un progrès même si je regrette
qu'il ne soit pas suivi d'un vote le
continent africain avec une population
projetée à 2 milliards et demi
d'habitants d'ici à 2050 est au cœur de
défis mondiaux il est le berceau mais
aussi l'avenir de l'humanité nous ne
pourrons faire face aux enjeux
économiques et envir économique
environnementaux et sécuritaires qui
liit nos pays et nos populations qu'à
travers une approche véritablement
collaborative et partenariale
c'est-à-dire en premier lieu
respectueuse de la souveraineté et de
l'autonomie des nations africaines la
France du fait de sa longue présence
coloniale et travers de ces multiples
interventions qu'elles soient
militairees ou économique est encore
trop souvent perçu comme une force
extérieure agissant exclusivement dans
son intérêt plutôt que comme un
partenaire véritable cette perception
nourrit les procès instruits à tort ou à
raison contre une supposée
France-Afrique ainsi que l'aurait
ironiquement qualifié l'ancien ministre
français et président ivoirien Félix
aufouette boignier période certes
aujourd'hui largement révolue mais dont
des rants toxiques qui n'ont pas
totalement disparu n'en finissent plus
d'empoisonner nos relations la politique
africaine de la France pour reprendre
une expression aussi malheureuse que
datée a été sous la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron marqué par une
dissonance entre les paroles et les
actes elle s'est heurté aux écueils du
ha en même temps cher au président de la
République mais qui se prête si mal à la
géopolitique et aux relations
internationales 6 ans après le discours
de wagadoudou faisons bilan en affichant
d'une part un soutien de façade à la
jeunesse et au diaspora engagé et en
apportant d'autre part un soutien bien
plus concret aux pouvoirs amis cette
logique a créé une politique du deux
poids de mesure les visites aux
autocrates et la faiblesse de nos
réponses diplomatiques aux crises qui
que traverse le continent ont terni
l'image et affaiblit la voix de la
France pour nen citer que quelques-uns
le soutien à alibongo puis à la
révolution de palais qui l'a renversé au
Gabon à mamati resdbi au Tchad et le
silence face à la répression massive
menée par Macky Sall au Sénégal ont
laissé un goût à mer cette politique
africaine est aussi sur un plan plus
large aveugle aux réalités de demain
celle d'un réchauffement climatique qui
va inévitablement bouleverser la manière
dont les hommes habitent le monde la
destructionction des écosystèmes et les
déracinements forcés mettront notre
humanité à rue d'épreuve ce que nous
nous voyons quotidiennement en
Méditerranée n'en sont malheureusement
que des prémisses c'est pourquoi le
tournant pris par notre politique
migratoire axé sur la restriction des
visas et sur les expulsions mais aussi
le débat public nasé àon qui l'entoure a
des répercussions profondes et
délétaires y compris à l'extérieur du
pays cela nourrit au sein des
populations africaines autrefois
francophile et toujours francophone un
sentiment un sentiment d'humiliation et
de rejet conduisant à notre effacement
du continent et au renforcement de
nouveaux impérialismes russes et chinois
notamment il est donc temps d'en finir
avec cette forme de xénophobie d'État
que traduit pourtant encore le nouveau
projet de loi sur l'immigration mais je
le concède il serait faux de faire
porter la responsabilité de de nos aans
en Afrique au seul président Macron
d'ancienne puissance colonisatrice
relativement passive face aux
transformations du du continent africain
c'est avec la désastreuse intervention
libyenne de 2011 que la France a
finalement de nouveau apporté son lot de
malheur la chute de kadfi que chacun ici
reconnaît comme un dictateur a entraîné
un afflux de combattants Tareg au Mali
exacerbant les tensions et les conflits
cette période a marqué le début d'une
une remilitarisation de notre action au
Sahel débouchant sur l'opération Serval
nécessaire pour handendiguer la poussée
du terrorisme puis sur la beaucoup plus
discutable opération barce voici la
réponse des écologistes monsieur le
ministre au paternalisme du discours de
Dakar où il avait dit que l'homme
africain n'était pas encore suffisamment
entré dans l'histoire Nicolas Sarkozi
ajouta alors les germes destructeurs du
néoconservatisme rompant avec la
tradition non interventionniste encore
incarnée par Dominique de vilpa en
2003 ce néoconservatisme qui consiste à
faire passer les intérêts de l'Occident
avant le droit international rejaillit
aujourd'hui avec le soutien
inconditionnel au massacre d'Israël en
Palestine et nous entraîne droit dans
une logique mortifère de guerre des
civilisations c'est cette même idéologie
qui a conduit au désastres en Afrique de
l'Ouest le Sahel déjà confronté au fléau
de l'extrême pauvreté devait désormais
aussi faire face à celui du terrorisme
et pour l'éradiquer nous avons calquer à
partir de cette effroyable grille de
lecture empruntée à la droite américaine
des schémas importés de leur croisade au
Moyen-Orient parfaitement inadapté au
maintien de la sécurité dans la région a
systématiquement chercher à rattacher
les djihadistes Maliens et des pays
voisins à des organisations comme
Al-Qaïda ou l'état islamique nous avons
sous-estimé les dynamiques locales et
sociales qui conduisaient à la
constitution de ces groupes cela nous a
amené à refuser tout dialogue avec eux
et à privilégier une une approche ultra
militarisé faisant fi des enjeux de
développement et laissant de côté les
dimensions économiques et politiques
pourtant indispensables au dénouement
des crises les années passant les
objectifs de nos armées devenaient de
moins en moins clair et le ressentiment
des populations à notre égard se faisait
lui toujours plus grandtisant nous
désignons comme des cibles de plus en
plus indiqués pour des gouvernants qui
n'arrivant plus qui n'arrivent plus à
convaincre de la justification de notre
présence et que nous n'entendions pas
quand il disait que nous étions
stratégiquement dans l'impasse la suite
nous la connaissons le 18 août 2020
despchist chassent le président ibeka de
Bamako imité le 30 septembre 2022 au
Burkina Faso leur première décision
seront de congédier nos armées auquell
ils préféront les terribles milices de
Wagner ces nouveaux gouvernants aidés
notamment par la Russie de Vladimir
Poutine nourrissant encore plus le rejet
de l'État français mais incapable
d'apprendre de nos erreurs nous avons
failli répéter ce scénario au Niger où
l'intervention de la France a dû être
empêchée par le président Bazou lui-même
aussi peut-être est-il temps d'enfin
reconnaître les limites de cette
approche expansionniste la stratégie du
ministère des armées telle qu'elle est
présentée aujourd'hui semble obéir à une
logique moins descendante et plus
intégrée avec les organisations locales
de la région je veux d'ailleurs
souligner l'exemple mauritanien grâce
auquel perdure le G5 S mais notre
présence en Afrique doit être repensée
dans une perspective radicalement
élargie dans son champ comme dans sa
logique intégrant un véritable soutien à
l'expression démocratique à la défense
de l'environnement et des droits humains
en somme les promesses de wagadoudou les
intentions étaient là et certaines comme
l'augmentation de l'aide publique au
développement ont été partiellement tenu
mais une partie de sa programmation a
été détricoté cet été par un comité de
haut fonctionnaires nous avons donc
besoin d'évaluer l'aide au développement
telle qu'elle a été votée dans la loi de
2021 c'est d'ailleurs ce que propose le
président bourlange par ailleurs nous le
nous le savons tous nous payons aussi au
Sahel le démantelllement de notre outil
diplomatique pendant trois décennies
vous nous dites de vouloir le réarmer
sur la durée madame la ministre très
bien mais nous ne pouvons nous contenter
d'une promesse présidentielle dans ce
domaine une loi de programmation est
nécessaire mais la question fondamentale
en réalité n'est pas là elle est celle
de la crédibilité et de la confiance les
erreurs accumulées sous la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron ont érodé la confiance
de nos partenaires africains les
décisions contradictoires les
engagements non honorés ont dessiné
l'image d'un pays incapable de respecter
sa parole face à ce constat il est
impératif de renforcer d'autres modes
d'action comme la diplomatie
parlementaire et la coopération
décentralisée ainsi que l'a dit ma
collègue ma collègue socialiste ces
échanges peuvent en effet être des
catalyseurs puissants dans le
renouvellement du lien entre les
communautés politiques en ce sens les
diasporas africaines doivent être
intégrés comme des acteurs clés de ce
renouveau faisons de ce Parlement une
passerelle entre les peuples un lieu où
les aspirations démocratiques les
projets de développement les échanges
culturels trouvve un écho et un soutien
et si je salue l'ouverture d'un cycle
sur l'Afrique dans cette assemblée je
regrette qu'à ce stade le choix de de de
l'instance de débat qui sera celle de
l'Assemblée nationale serait plutôt la
comm la commission défense et et et pas
la commission des affaires étrangères je
pense que nous avons aussi notre mot à
dire un lieu finalement où la voix de
l'Afrique est entendu et respectée voilà
ce que j'aimerais que devienne cette
Parlement car cette multitude de voix
qui s'entremellent et s'enrichissent
mutuellement sont le socle d'une
refondation véritable et profonde monde
en particulier un des liens les plus
forts et le plus ancien entre la France
et toute une partie de l'Afrique c'est
c'est évidemment sa langue son
apprentissage a été imposé par
l'esclavage perpétué par la colonisation
mais mais elle est aussi celle des
auteurs des poètes d'une certaine forme
de résistance un butin de guerre comme
l'a dit cathbiassine à l'indépendance de
l'Algérie elle est un beau symbole de
notre histoire dans toute sa complexité
elle est une langue de création mais
aussi une langue profondément politique
je crois ainsi fermement l'avenir de la
Francophonie comme vecteur de liberté et
d'entraide à condition qu'elle ne
redevienne jamais un vecteur de
domination culturel dans le cadre de
cette francophonie renouvelée les
questions d'adaptation au changement
climatique et de mise en œuvre de
nouvelle solidarité devront être
prioritaires nous devons concevoir des
projets qui répondent aux besoins
spécifiques des pays africains tout en
contribuant à la préservation des biens
communs à l'échelle globale une
université fr francophone de la mer
pourrait par exemple être crée à
noakchot ces coopérations devront par
ailleurs se traduire par des actions
concrètes qui permettront de mettre en
place une véritable collaboration dans
la gestion des crises humanitaires et
environnementales loin de tout jeu
politicien le terrible séisme qui a
frappé le Maroc nous en a rappelé la
nécessité avec une douloureuse acuité en
conclusion de notre débat chers
collègues je souhaite m'adresser
directement aux jeunesses africaines et
français qui bien souvent sont les mêmes
vous êtes les architectes d'un avenir
commun un avenir qui malgré de terribles
défis regorge d'espéran vous avez le
devoir de tracer un chemin inédit
d'adaptation et d'entraide un chemin qui
répond aux urgences de notre époque avec
audace et créativité il est temps d'
souffer un nouveau souffle démocratique
assez puissant pour qu'il Balae
définitivement les les relolants nausé à
bond d'une France-Afrique unanimement
rejeté engager apporte votre pierre à
l'édifice d'une société plus juste plus
verte et plus humaniste ensemble nous
pouvons écrire une nouvelle page de
notre histoire commune à condition comme
comme l'écrivait léopolde cédar sangor
que nous sachions répondre présent à la
renaissance du monde je suis convaincu
que nous pouvons y arriver et je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole pour
une durée de 2 minutes 10 minutes est à
Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq pour le groupe
Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
vous avez 10 minutes mon cher
collègue madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre messieur les présidents chers
collègues pour les députés communistes
et ultramarins du groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine intervenir sur
le thème des relations entre la France
et les États d'Afrique est un exercice
de répétition sans cesse renouvelé les
partenariats que vous appelez de vos
vœux ne seront jamais renouvelés tant
que vous n'aurez pas changé radicalement
le logiciel sur l'Afrique car
aujourd'hui faut-il vous le rappeler les
États d'Afrique sont indépendants
formellement et différents et beaucoup
désire trouver une seconde indépendance
dans la souveraineté politique
économique et financière prenez la
mesure de cette expression très
populaire sur ce continent et daignez
enfin comprendre à quel point elle vous
oblige en tant qu'ancien état ancien
état colonisateur en tant qu'État
occidental développé en tant que membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies si le président Macron a
décidé en septembre d'organiser un débat
au Parlement sur ce sujet et si vous
êtes encore et toujours là devant nous à
nous dire et à dire le même catéchisme
franco-français c'est que vous êtes
sourd et aveugle aux appels des peuple
d'Afrique il faut décoloniser vos
imaginaires et vos discours nous députés
communiste et ultr-amarin entretenons
des liens de fraternité avec des
partenaires et des amis d'une multitude
d'États africains et nous écoutons nous
les écoutons et grâce auquels nous
enrichissons nos réflexions et nos
propositions d'action que nous
disent-ils premièrement que le Fran CFA
est mortifère deuxièmement que l'aide
publique au développement doit être
réorientée vers le développement des
pouvoir régalien des états troisièmement
que l'analyse française des problèmes
africains uniquement sous angle
sécuritaire et militaire est une impasse
stratégique et politique et
quatrièmement que le respect à géométrie
variable du droit international détruit
notre crédibilité et qu'il est temps
d'en finir l'échec primordial de la
France post-coloniale c'est le franc CFA
et le franc Pacifique soit dit en
passant mais ceci est un autre sujet le
franc CFA est un instrument qui n'y a
plus aucune légitimité il est la relique
d'un temps révolu aux yeux des peuples
africains rendez l'indépendance
monétaire à ces états et vous verrez
rapidement les choses changer et évoluer
et ce n'est pas la perfi de
transformation du franc CFA en echo
proposé par Emmanuel Macron qui va
changer quelque chose puisqu'elle ne
règle rien toute l'économie des états
utilisant le franc CFA est aspiré vers
la zone euro et entrave le commerce
entre les membres de la zone Fran CFA
justement le franc CFA est donc un
instrument utilisé par les
transnationals pour les fraudes fiscales
et pour perpétuer les intérêts d'une
petite élite déconnectée des réalités
locales la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale et l'érosion fiscale devrait
d'ailleurs être un des chantiers que
nous devons mener en coopération avec
les États d'Afrique sur la politique
monétaire internationale la France doit
peser de tout son poids pour accélérer
la réforme des droits de tirage spéciaux
du Fond Monétaire International ce
panier de devise doit être mis au
service d'un ordre international
économique plus juste
voilà un premier pas le deuxième pas
consiste à changer votre vision de
l'aide publique au développement la
commencez par remiser aux oubliettes la
conditionnalité de l'APD au respect de
votre politique migratoire car le vrai
problème n'est pas là le vrai problème
c'est qu'au sein des pays des états
utilisant le franc CFA le taux de
pression fiscale c'est-à-dire le poids
des impôts dans la richesse nationale
est deux fois plus faible que la moyenne
des états de l'OCDE alors que les
besoins y sont énormes les états
souffrent de trop faible rentrée fiscale
en plus d'avoir saigné d'avoir été
saigné par trois décennies d'application
méticuleuse de la doxa néolibérale une
aide publique au développement une aide
publique au développement efficace
devrait servir à renforcer la
construction des états elle doit aider
ces pays à rendre performante leur
administration fiscale pour qu'ils
puissent ensuite faire leur propre choix
budgétaire utiliser des ressources
propres pour leur service publi
l'éducation la santé la sécurité les
infrastructures routières et
énergétiques pour cela les députés du
groupe GDR proposent d'ailleurs de
dédier 10 % de l'aide publique au
développement française Total au
renforcement des capacités des états et
de leurs services fiscaux pourquoi ne le
feriez-vous pas cela engendrera un
développement grâce aux forces vives du
pays et non pas maintenu plus ou moins
artificiellement depuis l'extérieur
notre logique c'est celle des gens à qui
l'on apprend à pêcher plutôt que leur
donner du poisson une troisème un
troisème pas consiste à modifier en
profondeur votre politique sécuritaire
et commerciale vis-à-vis du continent
l'intervention du Rwanda sur la demande
de la France au Mozambique pour pacifier
une région où travail total démontre
cette vision à la fois militariste de
notre action dans le continent et
également l'utilitarisme des de l'usage
de l'aide publique au développement la
réaction d'Emmanuel Macron suite à la
suite du coup d'État au nigère cet été à
sorti d'une menace de guerre menée par
la CDAO que Paris encourageait relève du
même réflexe mortifère pour ne pas
perdre accès à l'uranium nigérien que
nous achetons à bas prix les députés du
groupe GDR le disent depuis longtemps
engager une révision complète des
traités de coopération militaire et
engager le retrait des bases militaires
de tous les états sur ce continent car
on ne combat pas le terrorisme
uniquement par les armes mais par la
politique partout où il se trouent les
entrepreneurs de violence dont les
djihadistes se comportent comme des
mafias ils créent l'insécurité pour se
présenter en protecteur des populations
pour cela il profite du vide des
politiques publiques et de la faiblesse
des états une faiblesse que les États
comme la France ont encouragés en
subordonnant notre aide et notre
coopération à la signature d'accord avec
la Banque mondiale avec le Fond
Monétaire International avec le Club de
Paris qui avait pour but de supprimer
les services publics pour rembourser les
dettes nous soldons les comptes de
ceserm et lorsqu'il y a un coup d'État
comme au Mali ou au Niger qui prétend
reprendre la main en main la situation
sécuritaire si la France a pour seule
réponse des sanctions qui étouffe le
peuple sans gêner ses dirigeants il est
évident que cela n'améliorera pas
l'image de notre pays même si nous ne
soutenons pas les pchistes ce réflexe de
sanction a été catastrophique pour
l'image de la France le 4è pas qu'il
vous faudra faire pour recréer la
confiance entre la France et les États
d'Afrique c'est bien évidemment d'en
finir avec votre politique de deux poids
de mesures en tant que membre permanent
du Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
à ce titre les parlementaires
communistes et ultramarin portent l'idée
qu'il faut régler par le droit
international toutes les crises actuelle
et cesser de
tergiverser la crise au Sahara
occidental est une épine dans le pied de
de la France comme du Maroc pourtant le
droit dicte déjà tout ce qu'il faut
faire c'est simple comme un référendum
d'autodétermination comme on pu en
bénéficier l'ensemble des États
d'Afrique la présence française à
Mayotte issue d'un référendum
d'autodétermination déclaré nul et non
avenu par les Nations Unies doit être
discuté pour montrer notre bonne volonté
et parce que la la situation actuelle
n'est pas tenable il faudra construire
un avenir commun entre Mayotte et
l'archipel entre Mayotte et l'archipel
plus largement le fait que la France ne
critique pas le 3è mandat illégal du
président ivoirien Ouatara tout en
condamnant le même 3è mandat illégal du
président guinéen Condé démontre
l'arbitraire de notre diplomatie que le
président Macron aille en personne au
Tchad en 2021 pour adouber le fils du
président débi au poste de président au
mépris de la institution tchadienne
n'est pas digne de notre état non plus
les relations à géométrie variable de la
France avec certains dirigeants des pays
d'Afrique constitue l'une des raisons
principales du rejet de la France en
Afrique et ailleurs mais qu'on ne s'y
trompe pas il ne s'agit pas que de la
France c'est l'une des zones de fracture
du monde occidental avec de nombreux
autres États le dossier
israello-palestinien est aussi un sujet
en Afrique et les violations
quotidiennes du droit international par
Israël qui ne sont pas condamnés sont du
pain béni pour les États qui veulent
attaquer l'image des États occidentaux
refonder les relations entre la France
et les États africains consistera donc à
écouter les besoins les jeunesses qui
veulent la liberté la souveraineté et
qui veulent surtout pouvoir se former se
soigner vivre et grandir dans des
espaces pacifiés y travailler et se
développer dignement si vous faites ces
quatre premiers pas et que vous prenez
que ce sont les États africains c'est
aux États africains de mettre en place
leur propres décisions alors vous agirez
enfin dans le sens de la paix et du
renouveau du partenariat entre la France
et les États d'Afrique changer la
politique de la France vis-à-vis des
États africains et la seule voix pour
retrouver sa crédibilité sur la scène
internationale la France sera alors
porteuse d'une voix différente d'une
voix originale qui sera utile et écouté
avec intérêt par les peuples du monde
merci à vous merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue et la parole est à Madame
Estelle yououpa pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre M et territoire pour
une durée de 10
minutes merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le
ministreurés ident de la commission des
affaires étrangères chers collègues
l'Afrique est un continent capital pour
notre pays humainement historiquement
stratégiquement économiquement
culturellement intimement nos relations
avec l'Afrique sont profondes riches
complexes parfois conflictuelles et
douloureuses mais toujours
interdépendante et intense se pencher
sur le sujet n'est jamais superflu et le
débat qui se tient maintenant est
nécessaire je veux saluer à cet égard la
qualité du rapport d'information de nos
collègues Tabarot et fou sur la
politique française en Afrique rapport
qui fera date grâce à la vivacité de ses
analyses et la sincérité de son examen
de notre politique en Afrique impossible
de ne pas commencer par l'actualité
c'est-à-dire la succession de coups
d'État au Sahel depuis 3 ans et la fin
de l'opération barcane qui se sont qui
sont considérés comme des échecs
stratégiques français le recul brutal de
notre pays dans la région en est la
sanction nous devons au sacrifice de nos
58 militaires décédés au Sahel la
gratitude de la nation mais aussi un
questionnement rigoureux de la politique
qui a mené à cet échec caractérisé par
l'avancée territoriale des djihadistes
une montée du sentiment anti-français et
la fin de nos accords militaires pour
rappel les forces françaises étaient
engagées au Sahel de 2013 à 2022 et
pendant 9 ans les experts n'ont cessé de
répéter que pour le retour d'une
stabilité durable la France devait non
seulement faire un effort militaire mais
aussi et surtout de dialogue politique
élargi de lutte contre la corruption de
reconstruction économique au bénéfice de
tous la France était appelée au Sahel à
à traiter ses partenaires d'égal à égal
pour éviter d'alimenter la renqueœur du
passif colonial elle devait construire
une coalition large pour éviter un tête
à-tête malsin la lutte contre le
terrorisme n'est pas que militaire et
notre enfer peut-être bavé pavé de
bonnes intentions voilà des évidences
que notre pays semble avoir oublié et
payé cher au Sahel il ne s'agit pas ici
de refaire le film et bien de tirer des
leçons indispensables le recul de notre
influence en Afrique de l'Ouest
soulligne aussi les difficultés de notre
diplomatie à sortir de l'habitude des
relations privilégiées avec des
dirigeants contestés et contesta a
refusé de voir que la montée en
puissance de nouveaux partenaires met
fin à la Rand post-coloniale et exige de
rendre nos offres commerciales plus
compétitives l'Afrique avance et se
transforme rapidement l'environnement
stratégique évolue mais notre pays
semble lui englué dans un passé idéalisé
dans sa superbe perdue et nous
ressassons nos échecs en refusant toute
adaptation en vérité c'est à se demander
qui n'est pas rentré dans l'histoire
pour la députée de Mayotte que je suis
représentant ici le département français
le plus proche géographiquement de
l'Afrique la politique africaine de la
France n'est pas une abstraction nos
voisins immédiats sont je le rappelle
les Comor Madagascar la Tanzanie le
Mozambique et le Kenya la relation avec
les Comor est je dois le dire un
concentré des hermands Duqu d'orsé avec
un président modèle du genre pchiste
reçu avec tapis rouge à l'Élysée le
président azali atouani qui tire à
l'occasion sur sa population emprisonne
ses opposants mais qui est invité au
Forum de la paix à Paris et préside
l'Union africaine grâce aux bons offices
de notre diplomatie notre voisin
comorien est un champion avéré de la
corruption avec une mauvaise gouvernance
si grave que même les institutions les
mieux intentionnées n'arrivent pas à
fermer les yeux c'est sans compter la
générosité aveugle de l'Agence française
de développement qui s'obstine noté que
lafd opère en Outremer mais aussi à
l'étranger ce qui en dilon sur la vision
administrative des ultramarins passons
pour revenir au Comor ce pseudo
partenaire qui revendique Mayotte depuis
74 et qui instrumentalise les flux
migratoires pour asseoir son projet de
colonie de peuplement de notre île le qu
choisit avec Moroni une politique
d'accommodement coupable qui ne marche
pas Churchill disait qu'un conciliateur
est quelqu'un qui nourrit un crocodile
en espérant qu'il sera le dernier à être
mangé les Comores font monter les
enchères en allant à Moscou Beijing et
New Delhi Paris cède et Mayotte
s'enfonce votre politique madame la
ministre doit changer radicalement parce
qu'elle est visiblement en échec depuis
le début de mon mandat je vous alerte
madame colena sur l'inefficacité de
votre politique et vous me répondez que
votre ministère travaille effectivement
pour Mayotte regardons donc la chose et
reprenons votre argumentaire d'abord
l'accord de 2019 AC clé comomor dont
vous expliquez qu'il permet de faire
baisser la pression migratoire et
d'augmenter les reconduites à la
frontière alors voilà les chiffres de la
préfecture de Mayotte
27831 reconduites à la frontière en 2019
13301 en 2020 à cause du covid
23724 en 2021 et
25389 l'an dernier c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a moins de reconduite à la frontière
depuis la signature de l'accord de
moronnie nous pouvons considérer que
votre politique du chiffre n'a fait
qu'avaliser le projet de libre
circulation cher à vos diplomates et
combattu fortement par les maorés les
quissa Comoriens entrent à maotte comme
dans un moulin et nous payons nous le
billet retour au frais du contribuable
c'est un formidable jeu de dupe qui
valide le chantage migratoire alors que
la population comorienne augmente à
Mayotte malgré la signature de Moroni le
trafic humain et le marché des quissa
prospère avec l'aval de Moroni qui s'en
sont même vantés en dénonçant
l'opération ambouchou
les chiffres et les faits sont têtus
madame la ministre la politique de votre
ministère ne produit aucun résultat pour
Mayotte le deuxème axe de votre défense
et la reconnaissance de maillot françain
sur la thine internationale là-dessus
bizarrement vous êtes d'accord avec
Monsieur Lecoq vous vous félicitez
qu'aucune résolution n'a été portée à
l'ONU contre la France Vous saluez en
fait l'inertie puisque l'ONU ne
reconnaît toujours pas Maillotte
française ni le choix de ses habitants
pire les autorités russes mentionnent de
plus en plus Mayot pour affaiblir la
France là encore les faits sont étus la
politique de votre ministère ne produit
aucun résultat diplomatique pour Mayotte
enfin pour l'intégration régionale de
Mayotte sur laquelle vous dites que le
qu d'orsé travaille depuis 30 ans et
dont Mayotte est exclu par opposition
des Comores à ce jour je vous rappelle
que Mayotte ne fait toujours pas partie
des institutions de notre voisinage
d'aucun projet de la Commission de
l'Océan Indien dont la France est membre
qu'au titre de la Réunion alors que
notre pays est le principal bailleur de
fond de cette institution aucune mention
de Mayotte pendant la présidence
française de la COI en 2021 nos athlètes
sont toujours interdits de marseillaises
et de drapeau tricolore lors des
manifestations sportives de la région et
l'accueil des jeux de l'océan Indien à
Mayotte est un cass-etête diplomatique
pour vous là encore les faits sont
obstinés madame Colona la politique
comorienne du ministère des Affaires
étrangères ne produit aucun résultat
pour Mayotte mais Ellez un bel exemple
de ce qui ne va pas car depuis l'accord
de 2019 la France a engagé 150 millions
d'euros d'aide au Comor alors que
Mayotte subit une déstabilisation totale
du territoire organisé par l'immigration
comorienne saturation des services
publics dislocation de l'équilibre
social et politique affaiblissement de
l'autorité publique recul de notre
souveraineté c'est un cas d'espèce de ce
que l'Union européenne et l'OTAN
qualifie de menace hybride par
instrumentalisation des flux migratoires
je rappelle que la France est membre de
l'Union européenne et de l'OTAN
étonnamment lors des auditions que j'ai
mené pour la commission des affaires
étrangères sur le pacte européen sur la
migration et l'asile nos diplomates à
Bruxelles m'ont benoitement expliqué que
la question de la protection des
frontières de bagotte n'est pas soulevée
par la France au niveau de l'Union
madame la ministre les faits son là
votre ministère n'est pas mobilisé sur
les enjeux migratoires pour
Mayotte pourtant vous seriez bien
inspiré de vous engager davantage pour
notre territoire qui est la seule terre
franç 16 habité du canal du Mozambique
dont le gaz est opportunément plus
stratégique que jamais pour l'Europe
depuis la guerre en Ukraine Mayot est
effectivement un département français
vulnérable face à la menace terroriste
de daesh nichée à 500 km de nos côte au
Mozambique mais maotte est aussi un
sanctuaire tricolore au large de
l'Afrique un sanctuaire de plus en plus
précieux au fur et à mesure que la
présence militaire française s'étiole
sur le continent Mayotte et et son lagon
qui devrait être pivot dans la stratégie
Indo-Pacifique de notre pays parce que
notre île est en capacité d'accueillir
un port militaire français en eau
profonde sans subir une cohabitation à
la djibousienne monsieur le ministre des
Affaires étrangères l'a noté dans la loi
de programmation militaire notre
position stratégique est unique notre
pays ne peut pas et ne doit pas s'en
passer à cause du contentieux avec les
Comores j'ajouterai madame la ministre
que si la guerre en terin doit nous
apprendre quoi que ce soit c'est que
l'on n'jambe pas les peuples ni les
conflits territoriaux avec des accords
aveugles le temps qui passe ne fait
qu'en venimer la situation vous devez
régler ce conflit et défendre Mayotte
que la puissance de votre ministère que
la puissance de la France se mette enfin
tout entière en branle pour son
intégrité territoriale pour nous Mayotte
n'est pas comorienne mais française et
le qué d'orsé doit travailler activement
à le faire reconnaître
internationalement doit faire plier
moronie cet état parasite qui ne survit
qu'avec l'aide de notre pays utiliser
ces leviers financiers et politiques
contre Moroni n'est pas honteux c'est
votre devoir pour Mayotte pour vos
compespatriotes je vous remercie je vous
remercie ma chè collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Vincent ledou pour le groupe
renaissance pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
messieurs les présidents de commission
chers collègues notre perception des
partenariats entre la France et
l'Afrique ne doit pas être surdéterminé
par l'agitation de pchistes du Sahel et
d'influenceurs prrusses ou salafistes
deux exemples me paraissent révélateur
par une de ces polémiques
franco-françaises dont nous avons le
secret on nous affirmait il y a quelques
semaines que la France avait rompu tout
lien de coopération culturelle avec des
artistes du Sahel à la suite du coup
d'État au Niger sur certains bandes cet
hémicycle on faisait ressurgir le
spectre de la morgue et eu colonialisme
français mais évidemment il n'en était
rien les artistes maliens nigériens
burkinabé continuent de travailler avec
leurs homologues en France ou dans nos
réseaux culturels à travers toute
l'Afrique et vendredi dernier sidqu
Diabaté le prince de la Cora a enflammé
l'Arena de Paris- Bery les réseaux
sociaux en ont relayé les images à
bamaco suscitant des milliers de
témoignages de fierté que cet artiste
malien rend isse une grande salle
française un autre exemple concret dans
la commune 6 de bamaco l'espace culturel
hurgol café une initiative privée de
l'universitaire tiefing sisoko met à
profit les expertises scientifiques
universitaires professionnelles de la
diaspora malienne pour promouvoir
l'autonomisation des jeunes en
confrontant les acteurs du monde
économique et du monde de l'éducation
l'ambassade de France a aidé à nouer des
liens avec les alumnis ses anciens
étudiants en France et cette structure
est suivie par la Délégation de l'Union
européenne au Mali et par la Coopération
suisse malgré laaginte prorusse c'est un
témoignage remarquable des liens qui se
tissse encore entre le Mali la France et
l'Europe ainsi c'est en partant de la
réalité des liens franco-africains et de
la réalité des besoins et des attentes
de l'Afrique que l'on peut construire
une politique durable et tel est bien la
démarche que les ministres nous ont
présenté et qu'il nous revient
d'approfondir de fait depuis 2017 à
l'initiative du Président de la
République la France engager un vaste
agournento de sa politique africaine
afin de répondre aux attentes de
partenariats gagnant-gagnant nourrissant
des liens durables et plus égalitaire à
rebour de certains discours caricaturaux
il faut rappeler que ces orientations
impulsées par le président n'ont pas du
tout été définis en vase clos au
contraire elles ont été débattues
approuvées coconstruites publiquement
ici même avec des texte que nous avons
voté pour permettre la montée en
puissance et la réorientation de l'aide
publique au développement la réforme du
franc CFA ou encore le travail conjoint
sur le patrimoine africain les ministres
viennent de présenter en détail les
avancées considérable réalisé ces
dernières années ainsi que les enjeux de
réorientation de notre coopération
militaire et sécuritaire qui demeurent
essentiel en particulier pour appuyer
les pays du Golfe de Guinée dans la
lutte contre les groupes criminels
organisés qui tirent profit de la traite
des êtres humains des traficqus de
stupéfiant ou de la
cybercriminalité dans ce domaine comme
dans tous les domaines on construit de
partenariat qu'à partir d'un diagnostic
des besoins de chacun des partenaires
ceux des Africains comme les nôtres et
on ne construit un partenariat qu'avec
ceux qui veulent bien de nous cela
nécessite d'abord de connaître nos
partenaires de dialoguer avec eux de se
garder de toute appréciation à l'emporte
pièces ou de monter en épingle les
difficultés inévitables à des fins
politiciennes rien n'est plus
condescendant que les discours
misérabilistes de l'extrême gauche de
cet hémicycle qui cherche à faire des
Africains malgré eux la nouvelle
avant-garde de l'insoumission mondiale
après tout se disIl ce qui a si
formidablement échoué au Venezuela
pourquoi ne pas le recommencer au
Sénégal et bien mes chers collègues le
sol néocolonialisme qui s'exporte encore
de France c'est bien ce discours
caricatural pseudoavant et volontiers
conspirationniste complaisamment relayé
sur les réseaux sociaux qui croit
trouver la cause de tout les mots de
l'Afrique dans notre pays ou dans
l'Europe et pourquoi pas dans notre
président de la République cette posture
est non seulement dangereuse et funeste
mais elle est extrêmement préjudiciable
à nos partenaires africains eux-mêmes
qui veulent construire et non détruire
nous devons donc partir des besoins
réels en Afrique en regarder de façon
lucide les opportunités considérables
mais aussi les risques qu'il présentent
le problème de bon nombre de pays
africains c'est d'abord la pauvreté et
un déficite énorme en infrastructure de
base route pont énergie pour lesquels
nous sommes encore très loin du compte
comme me le confiait un ami sénégalais
très qualifié de la diaspora en France
dans sa ville d'origine les jeunes
privés de toutes perspectives
économiques partent en Mauritanie à
pirogue puis tente l'aventure vers la
Libye ou le Maroc à destination de
l'Europe ou vers le Nicaragua à
destination des États-Unis rien ne les
arrêtera tant que l'activité économique
ne leur permettra pas de sortir d'une
popérisation insidieuse et d'exercer
leur droit à ne pas migrer oui leur
droit à ne pas migrer cet enjeu saute
aux yeux de quiconque traverse le
boulevard du centenaire à Dakar qui est
un peu le poumon commercial de la ville
où des commerçants chinois emploi des
jeunes sans qualification ni diplôme ce
qui change un peu la vie de ces jeunes
africains et donne une bonne image de la
Chine alors même qu'il n'en résulte pas
de vraies perspectives structurant à
long terme pour le Sénégal notre
coopération économique doit donc être pr
prioritairement orienté vers des projets
concrets bien visibles qui créent de
l'emploi sur place ces partenariats
doivent intégrer la transformation
locale puis aider à commercialiser par
l'accès au marché européen où l'Afrique
est encore exposé à des barrières à
l'entrée l'action de la France doit
ainsi dès l'origine intégrer pleinement
les logiques européennes et les
instruments de soutien au développement
propres à l'Union car c'est un aspect
important des attentes des Africains
pour qui le partenariat avec la France
est un point d'entrée vers l'Europe
j'ajoute que le fait qu'il n'existe plus
aucune chasse gardée de la France en
l'Afrique est bon pour nous et bon pour
les Africains cela oblige nos
entrepreneurs à proposer des projets
d'excellence or le savoir-faire français
est bien accueilli en Afrique souvent
parce que nous avons le français en
partage ou grâce à une histoire commune
et toujours lorsque nous savons nous
montrer attentif à l'autre et soucieux
de bâtir des relations durables de
Digital Africa à Africa et bientôt ch
Africa 2 la France a clairement fait le
choix du soutien à l'entrepreneuriat
africain ces dernières années et de plus
en plus en lien avec des projets issus
des diasporas ce qui est une bonne chose
il faut désormais démultiplier cette
approche avec des projets à taille
humaine sur des biens de première
nécessité agriculture équipement urbain
éducation formation le président de la
République l'a très clairement dit dans
son discours du 27 février toutes les
forces de la société française doivent
être embarqué dans une diplomatie
partenariale les entreprises comme les
universités et les collectivités
territoriales c'est un P majeur de la
mise en relation concrète de société sur
lequel à la demande du Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe j'avais remis voici 4
ans un rapport au gouvernement sur les
échanges entre territoires français et
africains c'est-à-dire la coopération
décentralisé mais aussi les échanges
entre réseaux professionnel association
société civile il y a là un terraot
considérable que certains postes
diplomatique s'efforce de mobiliser mais
qui est souvent sous-utilisé il permet
de dessiner une autre géographie de
notre relation à l'Afrique loin des
idées reçues le lien entre les
territoires et les pays africains est
aussi une manière de mettre en avant une
France diverse et pluraliste qui dément
la centrilisation ou l'autoritarisme
caricaturé par nos détracteurs ces liens
démultipliés nous permettre de donner de
plus prise à nos adversaires nous
parlons alors de nous tels que nous
sommes et non pas un fantasme nous
donnons aussi accès à des guichets de
solutions partout sur notre territoire
pour outiller nos initiatives vers
l'Afrique ou accueillir les meilleurs
entrepreneurs et créateurs africains à
cet égard madame la ministre il me
paraîtrait utile de créer au sein de la
Direction générale de la mondalisation
une direction de l'internationalisation
des territoires et des acteurs de la
société civile afin de sortir des seules
logiques traditionnelles de la
coopération traditionnelle ou des ONG
mais pour mettre l'intelligence de nos
territoires de nos diasporas et de notre
jeunesse au service de cette relation
entre l'Afrique et la France notre débat
coincide par exemple avec la nouvelle
édition des appels à projets acteurs de
l'énergie pour l'Afrique concernant les
énergies renouvelables et la formation
professionnelle à la maintenance des
équipements et à la gestion des
ressources lancé par la région
haute-fance il mobilise des entreprises
locales des clusters des start-ups les
opérateurs le potentiel de l'équipe
France territorial est ainsi mobilisé
pour des partenariats permettant un saut
qualitatif africain et de père à père
avec les entreprises les entrepreneurs
les réseaux territoriaux peuvent
recenser les besoins en main d'œuvre
selon les spécialisation de ces
territoires cela permettra d'accélérer
le dispositif jeune pro mis en œuvre par
les antennes de l'OFI en Afrique qui
offre à des jeunes travailleurs
africains l'occasion de développer leur
expertise pour un temps limité en France
nous pourrons ainsi favoriser les
migrations circulairire afin que le
passage par l'Europe assure la montée en
compétence des professionnels africains
soit un accélérateur de développement
change les regards sur lesmigration
voici quelques exemples parmi beaucoup
d'autres chers collègues d'échanges
gagnant- gagnant élaboré à partir de la
réalité de nos besoins partagés et qui
naissent d'un dialogue avec l'autre au
plan économique comme en matière
culturelle l'enjeu est donc de bâtir des
communautés connectées qui se parlent et
qui créent ce sont elles qui écriront
notre futur commun et on y décelle pas
une once de discours caricatural
anti-français je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à madame la Présidente Le Pen pour le
rassemblement national pour une durée de
[Applaudissements]
minutes merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères chers
collègues en novembre 2017 à
l'université Joseph kiserbau de de
wagadouu le président Emmanuel Macron
avait ouvert son discours en annonçant
qu'il n'y avait plus de politique
africaine de la France et le 23 février
2023 à l'Élysée à la veille d'un
déplacement sur le continent il
confirmait ces mots sont toujours
d'actualité et bien une fois n'est pas
coutume je dois reconnaître que le
Président de la République a
magistralement résumé la situation il
n'y a plus en effet de politique
africaine de la France sous Emmanuel
Macron celle-ci a disparu elle s'est
envolée volatilisée dans un magma d'reur
d'incohérence et de contradiction dont
la sinistre mésaventure nigérienne de
ces derniers mois aura été le point
d'orgue les premiers à en prendre bonne
note et comment pourrait-il en être
autrement sont les Africains eux-mêmes
qui ne peuvent que constater
l'effacement de l'influence française
sur le continent contrairement au
président de la République je crois
quant à moi que la disparition de sa
politique africaine constittu un drame
pour la France et une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'Afrique comme je
Nimagine pas que l'inscription de ce
débat à l'ordre du jour par le
gouvernement vise à instruire le procès
en incompétence du président Macron ni
que le terme de partenariat renouvelé ne
reflète une quelconque volonté de mettre
un terme à ce qui nous sert depuis 6 ans
de politique étrangère permettez-moi de
me tourner vers l'avenir et dans la
suite de mon discours de njamena de mars
2017 de vous exposer ce que devrait être
et ce que sera si les Français le
décident la politique africaine de la
France avant cela il nous faut cependant
prendre acte du tsunami qui nous a
frappé du coup d'État malien d'août 2021
celui de Libreville le 30 août dernier
en passant par la Guinée cononakry le
BurkinaFaso et le Niger ce qui s'est
passé en Afrique francophone s'apparente
à un mouvement tectonique profond ce qui
fut notutre zone d'influence et de
solidarité prioritaire à basculer dans
une nouvelle ère une are marquée en
premier lieu par la défiance croissante
de l'Afrique toute entière vis-à-vis
d'un multilatéralisme pensé à Washington
et à Bruxelles selon des conceptions
mondialistes et
uniformatrices malheureusement la France
a sous-estimé l'importance de ce nouveau
contextte et la capacité effective de
subversion de son dispositif par ses
compétiteurs comme elle a sous-estimé
les attentes africaines à l'égard d'un
monde multipolaire qui lui donne plus
que jamais le loisir de choisir ses amis
ses partenaires et si nécessaire ses
protecteur la politique menée ces
dernières années au Sahel en est
peut-être la plus visible illustration
malgré le professionnalisme et le
courage de notre armée à qui je rends
ici un hommage appuyé Emmanuel
Macron a surestimé notre capacité à
changer la donne stratégique dans la
région et je ne parle pas de sa volonté
d'externaliser une partie de notre
diplomatie à l'Union européenne dont le
rôle joué dans cette région est là aussi
un échec plus grave cette stratégie va à
l'encontre même des intérêts de notre
pays malgré ce constat accablant comme
j'aime à le répéter il n'y a pas de
fatalité dans ce domaine aussi d'autres
choix politiques peuvent aboutir à
d'autres résultats il a en revanche une
forme d'urgence car nos compétiteurs ne
nous attendent pas et comme il est
compréhensible les Africains se tournent
vers les puissances qui paraisse le plus
en mesure de leur apporter les soutiens
dont ils ont besoin néanmoins notre pays
dispose sur le continent d'un capital
d'histoire et de langue partagé dont
j'ai la conviction qu'il nous permet
toujours de nous inscrire dans le temps
long de l'Afrique et de ne pas
désespérer j'entends donc proposer ma
vision d'une relation entre la France et
l'Afrique qui récuse les repentances
infondé et les nostalgies d'ENT temps
avec la même conviction je récuse
l'inscription de la relation
franco-africaine dans un cadre
multilatéral désincarné qui impose au
continent des modèles politiques
économiques et même anthropologiques qui
ne tiennent pas compte de son génie
propre comme je l'ai dit à cette même
tribune il y a tout juste un mois que ce
soit en Afrique ou dans d'autres régions
du monde la politique étrangère de la
France doit s'enraciner sur la
reconnaissance préalable de deux
certitudes l'existence des nations
participe à la diversité du monde et
donc à la richesse de l'humanité et la
considération des peuple et le respect
des nations sont des principes
essentiels à la paix et à l'harmonie du
monde vous le savez c'est cette
réflexion sur les relations
internationales et en particulier les
relations entre la France et les pays
africains qui m'ont amené à rédiger une
déclaration des droits des peuples et
des nations outil juridique qui pourrait
venir demain compléter le droit
international
entre l'utopie d'une coopération
asceptisée par la médiation d'un
multilatéralisme anonyme et une
France-Afrique qui ne peut et ne doit
plus exister j'ai la conviction qu'il y
a la place pour créer entre nos pays une
relation adulte basé sur la prise en
compte des réalités et des intérêts
légitimes dont les grands principes sont
précisément contenu dans cette
déclaration c'est aussi cette conviction
qui m'a amené il y a plusieurs mois à
proposer à l'occasion de mon voyage au
Sénégal que l'Afrique bénéficie d'un
siège de membres permanents au sein du
Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU je réaffirme ici comme je l'avait
fait devant feu le président déb que si
je veux que l'Afrique soit la première
des priorités internationales de la
France ce n'est ni par charité ni par
cupidité c'est tout simplement parce que
notre intérêt commun rencontre notre
amitié réciproque la France doit avoir
une politique africaine et au sein de
celle-ci des priorités et des alliances
privilégié avec ses amis historiques par
son histoire son savoir-faire technique
ses moyens et pour une large partie du
continent sa langue la France peut
accompagner positivement le processus de
construction et de consolidation des
états nation africains en se basant sur
le respect dû à nos partenaires quant au
choix souverain de leur politique et de
leur modèle de
développement sur ce sujet nous devons
être clair la noningérence dans les
affaires intérieures des états souverain
doit être notre règle d'action j'ai
d'ailleurs souhaité consacrer
solenellement ce principe dans l'article
3 de la Déclaration des droits des
peuples et des nations qui dispose que
les États déterminent librement les
éléments de leur statut politique et
poursuivre leur développement selon leur
volonté propre et sans ingérence
extérieure à titre
d'illustration je considère que
l'implication directe de l'armée
française sur le terrain devrait et
devra répondre à des objectifs
politiques et stratégiques précis être
limité dans le temps et disposer d'un
horizon de retrait clairement définie
j'entends aussi que cesse les
incohérences diplomatiques qui
alimentent l'incompréhension des
populations africaines à notre
égard la France ne peut pas à la fois
accepter la situation institutionnel
créé au Tchad après la mort du président
Idriss Deb tout en condamnant le Mali
d'assimig goitar en reconnaissant la
jeinte du colonel d'amiba au Burkina
Faso en envisageant de faire la guerre
au régime nigérien via la CDAO et en
donnant son feu vert au coup d'État mené
au Gabon par le général bris oliging
guema il arrive un moment où les
subtilités théoriques se transformment
en argusir rhtorique qui finissent en
douloureusees contorsion et fait le lit
du sentiment de de poids de mesur je le
dis sans ambage si nous ne sommes plus
compris de nos amis africains dans les
chancelleries comme dans la rue c'est
parce que nous ne sommes tout simplement
pas
compréhensibles ce qui revient à
dérouler un tapis rouge à toutes les
interprétation et manipulation de nos
concurrents or pour comprendre les
enjeux être compréhensies pour nos
partenaires bref pour mener une
politique étrangère digne de ce nom nous
avons besoin d'experts cela nécessite de
renforcer la formation des diplomates
d'agents de renseignement et de militair
aux relations bilatérales et non se
mettre de mettre en place pardon une
absurde réforme du corps diplomatique je
note d'ailleurs que la question des
moyens humains est assez longuement
évoquée dans le rapport de nos collègues
fou et
Tabarot aujourd'hui peut-être même plus
qu'hier les enjeux communs que j'évoqué
plus haut les sujets où les intérêts de
la France et ceux des pays africains
convergent ne manqu pas démographie
énergie environnement
sécurité devant une telle liste
l'absence de politique africaine
revendiquée par le Président de la
République apparaît comme une absurdité
une incongruété j'ose dire une faute
politique alors que le continent a dû
faire face au choc de la pandémie puis
aux effets dévastateurs de l'inflation
induite par la guerre en Ukraine et la
désorganisation des marchés alimentaires
il est temps que la France renoue avec
une politique africaine qui constituera
le cadre des partenariat qu'elle
proposera en toute transparence à nos
amis africains une politique africaine
qui réponde à une définition clarifiée
de nos intérêts dans cette partie du
monde en particulier la prévention des
migrations la sécurisation de nos
ressortissants la dynamisation de la
Francophonie et le développement de nos
échanges commerciaux qui sont
scandaleusement insuffisants je rappelle
en effet que la zone franc ne représente
que 06 % du commerce extérieur français
et puisque j'évoque la francophonie
permettez-moi de m'arrêter quelques
instants dessus la Francophonie est en
effet l'autre grande réalité humaine qui
doit structurer notre partenariat avec
l'Afrique car elle trouve sur le
continent africain un cadre de
développement naturel la francophonie
n'est pas à mes yeux la route secours de
l'influence française comme le disait
Léopold seddar sangor la Francophonie
est un mode de pensé et d'action
un canal naturel de dialogue et
d'échange pour les pays ayant le
français en partage et pour près de 300
millions d'hommes et de femmes de par le
monde dont beaucoup vivent sur le
continent la Francophonie est
essentielle parce qu'elle apporte au
monde en terme de préservation de la
diversité culturelle et linguistique
mais elle doit apparaître aussi comme
directement utile à la jeunesse
africaine au-delà de la langue qui doit
bien sûr servir à promouvoir les
coopérations éducatives scientifiques
universita
technique la francophonie devra être la
base du développement d'une véritable
union francophone don j'ai d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion de présenter les grandes
lignes durant la campagne présidentielle
avec notamment un volet économique et
financier comportant la création d'une
banque de développement de la
Francophonie à laquelle serait adjointe
une agence francophone de promotion de
l'industrialisation en Afrique cette
agence pourrait notamment relancer
l'initiative portée il y a quelques
années par Jean Louis borlau
d'électrification de l'Afrique à plus
court terme je suis convaincu qu'il faut
dépasser la notion d'IDE publique au
développement qui est une notion
étroitement budgétaire pour redonner
tout son lustre au concept de
coopération la coopération rénovée c'est
notamment la promotion des
investissement pour aider l'Afrique à
réussir son industrialisation et sa
montée en gamme technologique et
productive pour l'aider dans cette voie
il manque aujourd'hui à la France un
ministère de la coopération qui assure
la tutelle effective de l'agence
française de développement et qui
donnerait des impulsions conformes à une
loi d'orientation de 5 ans qui devrait
être voté après un large débat cette loi
devrait notamment avoir pour objectif de
donner un avenir à la jeunesse africaine
sur le sol
africain que les choses soient claires
l'avenir de la jeunesse africaine ne
peut et ne doit pas être la migration il
est urgent de mettre un terme à la
situation mortifère que nous constatons
depuis des années sur ce point je
reprends avec constance les mots que
j'adressais aux Afric am en 2017 ceux
qui partent sont souvent dynamiqu et
audacieux c'est la C vitale de vos
peuples qui s'échappe alors que vous
avez tant besoin d'eux pour relever les
innombrables défis de l'avenir leur
faire croire le contraire est non
seulement dangereux pour eux mais aussi
à l'opposé de la volonté du peuple
français au nom duquel je vous le
rappelle chers collègues nous
légiférons nous avons donc français et
africain maintenant la responsabilité de
tout faire pour voir aboutir un cercle
vertueux qui amènera 2 milliards
d'Africains à vivre de leur travail
selon leurs valeurs propres leur propre
identité et leur propre culture sous la
gouvernance d'État stable c'est
l'intérêt de la France c'est l'intérêt
des pays africains et c'est plus
largement une nécessité pour la
stabilité du monde partant de ces
intérêts de notre pays en Afrique
intérêt que nous n'avons pas à cacher
parce qu'ils sont légitimes et donc
compréhensibles par tous découleront des
objectifs logiques des politiques
publiques cohérentes et des moyens
adaptés la politique africaine de la
France doit redevenir une réalité et
nous donner ainsi un réel instrument de
solidarité internationale et un outil de
rayonnement et de sécurité au bénéfice
partagés de l'Afrique de notre pays et
d'une histoire commune après 6 ans de
macronisme et une telle dégradation des
relations entre la France et les peuples
et nations africaine je n'ai pas un mot
à enlever à mes propos adressés aux
Africains travaillons ensemble dans le
respect et la confiance à la
construction d'un futur qui verra nos
peuples vivre dignement chez eux tout en
s'ouvrant d'autant mieux les uns aux
autres qu'ils seront qui ils sont d'où
ils viennent et où ils vont je vous
remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Arnaud legal
pour le groupe la France insoumise pour
une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la Présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président
collègues l'exécutif a enfin consenti à
ce que soit mis à l'ordre du jour un
débat sur les relations entre la France
et les pays africains hasard du
calendrier la semaine passée un rapport
bienvenu de no collègu fou et tarot sur
ce crucial a été rendu publicque malgré
l'abstention des collègues de
renaissance plus personne de bonne foi
ne doute donc désormais du fait qu'il y
a une grave crise des relations entre la
France et nombre de pays africains
notamment
francophones ce débat Parlement aire
devrait donc être je cite la première
étape d'un processus démocratique
consultatif et transparent pour repenser
en profondeur l'avenir de nos relation
avec les pays africains je cite là une
récente tribune de dizaines de
responsables d'ONG de chercheurs
d'anciens
diplomates qui rappelle que le rejet
exprimé dans des proportions variables
au quatre coins de l'Afrique francophone
ne vise pas la France et les Français en
général mais bien la politique menée au
nom de notre pays nous avons fait notre
ce constat depuis longtemps il faut donc
en finir avec la des débats erratiques
et purement formel puisque non suivi
d'un vote le Parlement doit être saisi
et décidé et non simplement s'exprimer
sur des positions prises dans
l'opacité ce déficit démocratique n'est
pas un détail il est au cœur du désastre
pour qu'enfin on nous accorde ce temps
de débat sans vote il aura fallu un
affaiblissement sans précédent certains
diraient un effondrement de nos
relations en Afrique or la stratégie ou
l'absence de stratégie de la France en
Afrique depuis des années est d'abord le
résultat de décision et non décision de
l'entre soi élyséen il y a eu une suite
de choix erroné de faute d'aveuglement
comment put-on croire par exemple que la
militarisation quasi exclusive de nos
relations avec le Sahel mènerait
ailleurs que dans le mur si les
interventions militaires depuis 2011
n'expliquent pas tout elles ont eu un
impact
décisif cela a commencé avec
l'intervention en Libye qui a conduit au
prix d'un détournement du mandat onusien
initial à un changement de régime plus
qu'hasardeux avec un effet désastreux
sur la situation sécurité de tout le
Sahel il y eu ensuite l'opération sarval
ses premiers succès indéiables puis son
prolongement sans fin dans un cadre
opaque sous la forme de barcane je veux
rendre hommage comme tous et tout ici à
nos soldats morts ou blessés au combat
au Sahel depuis
2013 nos armées ont obtenu de nombreuses
victoires tactiques mais le cadre
stratégique était défaillant l'approche
strictement militaire n'était pas adapté
à la réalité dès 2013 nous avertissions
qu'une intervention sans plan ni retrait
ni projet politique partagés aboutirait
à une impasse après
l'augmentation croissante de l'influence
des groupes armés au Sahel après trois
coups d'État que nos services n'ont pas
vu venir beaucoup ici conviendront qu'il
aurait été préférable de ne pas se
contenter sur le sujet d'un seul vote de
la représentation nationale en 9 ans
initialement accueilli à tort en sauveur
notre pays est désormais considéré tout
aussi à tort comme responsable de tous
les mots au sel après une guerre sans
débat nous avons dû vivre encore une
retraite sans discussion ni bilan le
gouvernement s'abrite derrière une
explication facile l'existence d'une
propagande hostile notamment russe
nouvelle manière de prendre les peuples
de la région pour des pantins sans
conscience propre car la vérité est que
cette propagande qui n'est pas nouvelle
en soi naurait aucune prise si notre
pays n'avait pas été aussi exposé par
des choix
inconséquents pire la crise multiforme
affectant nos relations avec nombre de
pays africains ne se limite pas au Sahel
dans l'Afrique francophone le crédit est
entamé nous pouvons en Témo ign pour
nous être récemment rendu en République
démocratique du Congo premier pays
francophone du monde pas de rupture mais
la défiance existe et il y a
urgence alors il n'y a pas de solution
miracle pour sortir le lornière dans un
contexte international où n ne
maîtrisons qu'une partie des paramètres
mais commençons déjà par changer le fond
et la forme de la politique de notre
pays en Afrique d'abord abandonnons tout
paternalisme à l'Élysée on a pas rompu
avec le vieil imaginaire les sommets
convoqués sans ménagement les sermons
chefs d'État africains les gestes et
paroles vexatoires qu'on ne se
permettrait jamais en Chine ou aux
États-Unis les petites blagues
condescendantes ont laissé de mauvais
souvenirs en Afrique ensuite cultivons
l'entraide oui remplissons les
engagements sur les 0,7 % du PIB dévolu
à l'aide publique au développement mais
surtout inscrivons cette aide dans une
logique d'entraide en RDC nous l'avons
dit sur place nous sommes é aussi pour
apprendre pour échanger cette démarche a
été appréciée car elle correspond à
l'intérêt mutuel des peuples et puis
finançons-en avec la pratique
désastreuse du double standard et du
deux poids de mesure comment dénoncer
ici les coups d'État et là ad douber
leurs auteurs comme au
chchad comment dénoncer certains
massacres et en légitimer d'autres
croit-on vraiment que les peuples ne
voient pas cela ce double discours ces
contradictions sappent la crédibilité de
notre pays enfin redonnons à la
politique de la France en Afrique les
moyens nécessaires à sa cohérence le
rapport fou Tabaro esquisse des pistes
oui il faut redonner au ministère des
Affaires étrangères un rôle central et
oui cette chambre est en dépositaire de
la souveraineté il faut associer
étroitement le
Parlement cela pourrait aider à en finir
avec certaines absurdité absurdité du
fait que le dossier du Fran CFA dont la
charge politique est immense n'est prise
en charge que par Bercy absurdité d'une
politique de visa sur laquelle le MAE
n'exerce plus de compéten réell qui
obéit aujourd'hui à des logiques ob onal
éloignant de nous de nombreux étudiants
acteurs économiques et même dignitaires
politiqu africain qui se voi fermer la
porte se donner les moyens d'une
politique cohérente c'est aussi re
rebâtir notre expertise civile après
plus de décennies d'attrition de notre
présence dans les sociétés africaines
nous n'avons jamais remplacé les 10000
coopérants présents sur le continent il
y a encore 30 ans contre quelques
centaines aujourd'hui leur présence
était une grande ressource sans ignorer
les travers que pouvait aussi évidemment
appliquer cette coopération à l'ancienne
reconnaissons qu'elle permettait de
mieux comprendre la diversité des
contextes politiques économiques sociaux
sur ce grand continent elle prémunissait
contre le désastreux fonctionnement en
vase clos depuis
Paris la réduction drastique de ces
moyens d'information et compréhension
essentiel éclairent certains choix très
dommageables pour ne prendre que deux
exemples comment avoir pensé qu'il était
pertinant de voter une nouvelle
convention d'extradition judiciaire
France-Sénégal au moment même où le
gouvernement sénégalais instru
instumentalisait la justice contre le
principal opposant et provoquaer la
colère de toute la jeunesse du pays
comment ne pas voir qu'il faut aider
davantage la République démocratique du
Congo dans sa dans face à l'agression
dont est victime de la part du Rwanda la
RDC connaît dans l'indifférence générale
la pire crise humanitaire au monde près
de 7 millions de déplacés internes
cumulés depuis 30 ans une situation de
guerre qui perdure malgré la fin
officielle en 2003 d'un conflit le plus
meurtrier depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale alors tout n'est pas de la
faute de la du Rwanda en RDC mais comme
le dit l'ONU et même notre ministère des
Affaires étrangères oui le Rwanda a une
responsabilité écrasante dans la
continuation des combats et pourtant pas
un mot de tout cela au sommet de l'État
pour dénoncer cette responsabilité c'est
pourquoi nous continuerons avec mon
collègue Carlos bilongo apporter notre
proposition de résolution condamant le
soutien de la République du Rwanda au
groupe Rebell du M23 au-delà de ces cas
particulier l'enjeu est de savoir si
notre péri serura au rendez-vous de
l'histoire car l'Afrique contrairement à
ce que pu dire un ancien président de la
République sait l'histoire de grands
historiens en France même sont là pour
nous le rappeler une histoire qui est
aussi la nôtre une histoire d'échange
d'Inter d'interdépendance croissante de
construction commune de créolisation que
cela plaise ou non une histoire de
combat et d'émancipation toujours en
cours aujourd'hui plus de 60 ans après
les indépendances politiques les peuples
réclament une seconde indépendance et
réaffirment clairement leur souveraineté
sans formule préconstruite mais en
s'inspirant des libumba ou d'un Sankara
sans confondre souveraineté et obsession
identitaire mais avec
détermination cette réaffirmation de la
souveraineté des peuples africains
rencontre encore une fois l'histoire du
monde les transformations de l'ordre
géopolitique qu'on le veuille ou non
l'Afrique continent dans 50 % des des
habitants au moins de 18 ans est au cœur
de
l'avenir au lieu de se couper de ce
continent le plus francophone qu'il soit
sachons écouter ce que disent les
peuples ils ne veulent plus de sauveurs
de parins mais cherchent des partenaires
prêts à traiter d'égal à égal c'est
pourquoi nous devons développer en
Afrique ou ailleurs une politique
étrangère non alignée non réduite au
maniquéisme mortifère et la politique de
la peur le monde passe d'un monde
unipolaire à un monde apolaire chaque
nation doit redéfinir ses propres
alliances les vieilles logiques de blocs
sont dépassés et il faut rebattir un
monde ordonné pour faire face au grands
défis du siècle changement climatique et
effondrement de la biodiversité
explosion mondiale des inégalités crise
du système de sécurité collective crise
permanente d'une néolibéralisme
proposons renforçons de nouveaux espaces
de droit au sein de l'ONU et dans les
autres arènes compétentes autour de BI
commun d'intérêt général climat forêt
grand fond marin Espace Santé Publique
et cetera et cetera saons bien sûr
oublier ce bien commun suprême qu'est la
paix si mal mené par le remoncement à
appliquer le droit cette diplomatie des
causes communes cette diplomatie
altermondialiste doit avoir pour point
de départ notre relation avec les pays
africains si nous sinon nous tournerons
le dos à notre propre histoire et nous
nous rabourgrirons je vous
remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
fux pour le groupe démocrate pour une
durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président
la commission des affaires
étrangères notre débat intervient à un
moment très paradoxal il intervient à un
moment où à première vue la France n'a
jamais été autant contestée depuis les
indépendances et pourtant notre
conviction intime et que c'est
aujourd'hui que nous avons le plus de
chance de parvenir à créer de nouvelles
relations égales respectueuses et qui
garantissent leses intérêts des partis
si nous affichons devant la
représentation nationale cet après-midi
l'espoir d'y parvenir c'est que nous
possédons nous Français un nombre non
négligeable d'avantage comparatifs
d'abord il faut constater que nous avons
dans une grande partie des pays
d'Afrique anglophone ou luusophone une
bonne image et nos échanges commerciaux
il progressent comme l'a dit Madame la
Ministre s'agissant de l'Afrique
francophone nous Français nous n'avons
pas de mauvaise images il faut le dire
nous sommes toujours plutôt appréciés en
Afrique nous aurions tort de penser que
les Africains ne veulent plus de nous en
revanche ce qu'ils nous disent ce qu'ils
veulent c'est la France autrement et
c'est sur ce autrement qu'il faut nous
porter notre analyse et l'ensemble de
nos efforts ensuite depuis 2017 sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République beaucoup a déjà été engagé
beaucoup a été dit déjà depuis le
discours de wagadougou nous avons par
exemple entrepris un travail sur la
mémoire doubler le montant de notre aide
au développement entamer un processus de
restitution des œuvres d'art engager la
transformation du Fran CFA même s'il
reste encore à terminer le processus
enfin nous avons depuis longtemps
déployé un nombre de politiques
publiques performantes et exemplair
c'est un point fort de notre relation
avec Les Afriques nous avons nourri de
longues dates une tradition d'engagement
solidaire que ce soit en matière d'accès
à la santé de conservation la
biodiversité encore de lutte contre le
changement climatique et notre
engagement est remarquable aussi d'un
point de vue de entrepreneuriat de la
formation ou encore de l'égalité des
chances dès lors lorsque l'on met en
rapport toutes ces politiques publiques
mené par la France et l'image actuelle
de la France on peut effectivement
ressentir une forme d'injustice ou de
frustration tous nos efforts sont en
effet masqués par des attitudes euh ou
des pratiques issues du passé tant que
nous n'aurons pas définitivement soldé
ou éradiquer ces irritants ces chiffons
rouges comme euh le pour reprendre
l'expression du professeur haschid
membbeé il nous sera quasiment
impossible de redémarrer un nouveau
cycle fécond avec nos partenaires
africains c'est dans cette optique qu'il
nous faut procéder sans tabout et à une
introspection et pour être efficace il
faut le faire en toute locidité et sans
aucune complaisance première idée nous
n'avons pas vu ou voulu voir l'Afrique
évoluer or l'Afrique n'est plus la même
que celle qu'on a connu il y a 10 20 ou
30 ans si on prend uniquement l'angle de
la démographie en 2050 l'Afrique
habitera plus de 2 millards 400 millions
d'habitants ils seront 4 milliards ou
plus de 4 milliards en 200 au Niger on
est passé de 3 millions d'habitants en
1960 à 70 millions en 2060 en 100 ans le
continent africain très jeune est devenu
une terre attractive de fortes
compétition la Chine a injecté 150
milliards de dollars de dons en 20 ans
elle est désormais le premier partenaire
commercial de l'Afrique avec 27 % des
parts de marché l'Inde compte près de
2700000 ressortissant en Afrique
l'Allemagne est parvenu à pénétrer le
marché africain à un niveau similaire à
celui de la France il nous faut beaucoup
mieux comprendre et nous adapter
d'urgence à cette nouvelle donne et
comme le disait déjà le président de la
République en 2017 ce changement profond
qui consiste à revoir à révolutionner
toute notre façon de penser c'est est
indispensable deuxième idée ce dé faire
des irritants qui ont progressivement
altéré notre relation en premier lieu
nos attitudes quand je dis nos c'est
l'ensemble des Français bien évidemment
il n a pas de stigmatisation de la
classe politique en particulier nos
attitudes paternalistes ou jugés
paternalistes et parfois condescendantes
les Africains ne les supportent plus il
nous faudra solder définitivement notre
passé colonial il faut terminer avec la
la réforme du francefa entreprise en
2019 et non achevé et même si ce sont
pays africains de le faire dans
l'intervalle c'est comme l'aannoncé le
ministre le Cornu également il nous
faudra redéfinir nos emprises militaires
et le rôle de nos armées en Afrique dans
l'intervalle C laisse libre cours à
toutes les spéculations et toutes les
malveillances cela passe aussi par une
refonte radicale de notre politique de
délivrance des visas elle a démarré
comme l'a dit Madame la Ministre et tout
en gardant la maîtrise de nos flux
migratoire je veux dire un petit mot sur
ce sujet-là car cette situation nous est
très préjudiciable comment expliquer que
le premier de la classe du lycée mermose
d'Abidjan qui a fait toute sa scolarité
dans des lycées ou des institutions
françaises se voir refuser un visa
aujourd'hui il poursuit ses études au
Canada comment expliquer que le
vice-président d'un parlement d'un grand
pays francophone qui est en possession
d'un passeport diplomatique d'une note
verbale de son ministre se voit refuser
un visa pour aller à une réunion sur la
francophonie comment se fait-il enfin
qu'une chef d'entreprise qui veut
investir en France demande des visas
pour que ses collaborateurs viennent se
former pendant quelques semaines en
France se voit refuser les visas elle
achètera donc son matériel en Inde et
tous ces collaborateurs seront formés en
Inde il nous faut enfin et ça a été dit
aussi terminer avec ce qu'on appelle le
double standard au fil du temps notre
position est parfois devenue un peu
illisible pour solder définitivement ce
qu'on appelle la période de la France
Afrique il nous
faut réinterroger notre doctrine issue
du discours prononcé par François
mitteran en 1990 à laabaule de façon un
peu schématique ou réductrice à la fin
des indépendances le général de Gaulle
pose la doctrine suivante une doctrine
claire sécurité et aide aux pays
africains contre loyauté et notamment
vote à l'ONU dans son discours de la B
François mit rajoute une condition il
souhaite donc continuer cette
collaboration en ne le faisant qu'avec
les pays qui engage des processus
démocratiques ce n'est pas tant la
doctrine plutôt vertueuse qui va créer
la confusion mais son application car
dans les faits l'ensemble des
gouvernements successifs ont été
incapables de mettre en œuvre de façon
cohérente et rigoureuse cette doctrine
il en résilte depuis des doutes et des
suspicions sur les vrais objectifs de la
France et sur l'existence d'un agenda
caché on pourrait se dire il ne faut pas
dramatiser c'est vrai que l'expression
du désenchantement est circonscrite et
elle n'existe pas en Afrique non
francophone où notre image est encore
positive mais nous pensons exactement
l'inverse il nous faut agir d'urgence
pour éviter un risque de contagion à
l'ensemble du continent et une perte
durable d'influence de la France il nous
faut donc clairement et c'est notre
objectif dire quel est notre intention
euh par rapport au soutiens au régime
non démocratique une intention qui doit
être cohérente dans toutes les
situations sur ce point je préconise
d'apporter et d'adopter l'approche
d'ashil membé la juste distance
démocratique et politique en clair la
France préserve et conserve ses valeurs
avec force elle avec force mais elle
n'intervient plus dans les affaires
intérieur des pays du continent africain
en revanche elle propose un certain
nombre de défis communs à résoudre de
projets à mener ensemble et de manière
bilatérale voire à l'échelle du
continent elle devra également très
clairement communier ses objectifs et
ses intérêts en Afrique et enfin elle
doit s'engager à apporter des résultats
et une vision opérationnelle à ses
partenaires une fois que c doctrine sera
clairement énoncé la mise en œuvre de
notre nouvelle doctrine nécessitera
d'être capable de mobiliser et
transformer tous nos leviers très
rapidement une forte reconnaissance au
diaspora qui doute encore aujourd'hui
réarmer notre diplomatie et constituer
une filière Afrique au qu d'orset
repenser l'aide au développement comme
quelque chose qui profite plus
directement aux populations et qui soit
le bras armé de notre stratégie
d'influence il nous faudra aussi
convaincre et entraîner tous nos
partenaires européens comme nous avons
suffi le faire lors du covid ou de la
guerre en Ukraine vous l'avez compris
nous pensons qu'il n'est pas trop tard
pour réenchanter nos partenariats avec
les différents pays africains mais que
c'est au contraire le bon moment de le
faire une fois que nous avons identifié
les questions qui fâche et que nous
avons trouvé les moyens de les dépasser
et de les supprimer car comme on dit en
Afrique c'est au bout de la vieille
corde contisse la nouvelle tout est
encore possible donc mais il faut fsser
vite même très très vite et il faut
changer de logiciel très rapidement
comme je viens rapidement bien sûr de
façon synthétique de vous le dire car en
réalité les enjeux sont bien plus
importants qu'une simple perte et au
renforcement de notre influence ce qui
est en jeu c'est tout simplement notre
avenir et le modèle de société dans
lequelle nous voulons vivre aujourd'hui
notre modèle d'état de droit de liberté
publique de vision multilatéral au
universaliste est en danger face aux
intégrismes religieux face aux
impérialismes politiques au nationalisme
autoritaire au libéralisme sans foi au
populisme le réenchantement de nos
relations avec nos partenaires africains
conditionne tous simplement la question
de notre avenir madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
chers collègues c'est tout simplement
notre avenir et ce de nos enfants qui se
joue dans le réenchantement de notre
relation avec
l'Afrique merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à présent à
Madame Amélia lacraffi pour le groupe
renaissance pour une durée de 15
minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues c'est en tant qu'élu des
Français d'une vaste circonscription qui
comprend 80 % de l'Afrique que je
m'adresse à vous aujourd'hui c'est un
grand honneur sur cette relation entre
renouveler entre la France et l'Afrique
dans la perspective de cette politique
que notre pays met en place et a déjà
mis en place depuis bien 6 ans impulsé
par le président par le Président de la
République ma fonction me permet en
effet de me rendre fréquemment sur le
continent africain afin d'y rencontrer
les Français qui sont installés dont
plus de la moitié sont binationaux mais
aussi les parlementaires du continent
les responsables politiques les membres
des gouvernements et les représentants
de la société civile et je souhaite donc
ici vous rituer mon analyse quant à
l'état de nos relations avec l'Afrique
dans le contexte
actuel la première évidence sur laquelle
je souhaite insister ici c'est qu'il n'y
a pas une Afrique je le rappelle très
souvent que l'Afrique est un continent
de 54 nations pas un pays homogène alors
il est mal venu de parler d'un sentiment
français généralisé en Afrique à vrai
dire actuellement seul trois ou quatre
des 54 pays africains expriment un
sentiment anti-français marqué et cela
souvent en raison de PCH
antidémocratique
honnêtement être critiqué par des
bouistes n'est pas un déshonneur au
contraire certaines nation extérieure
profite de cette minorité bruyante pour
déstabiliser cette relation
franco-africaine il s'agit de manœuvre
politique et financière que nous ne
devrions pas laisser obscurcir le
tableau général depuis l'élection du
Président de la République Emmanuel
Macron en 2017 la France connaît un
renouveau de ses relations en Afrique y
compris en Afrique de l'Est son discours
de wagadouu aborderé des questions
essentielles à la jeunesse africaine des
questions que ces mêmes jeunes
revendiquent aujourd'hui regardez donc
le Québec une ancienne colonie française
le Québec ne ressent pas le besoin de
trouver des bouces émissaires à
l'extérieur pour exprimer ses défis
intérieurs donc j'insiste il est grand
temps de valoriser les 50 pays africains
qui entretiennent une relation positive
avec la France et ne pas se laisser
distraire par une minorité qui ne
représente pas l'Afrique dans sa
diversité et sa complexité je souhaite
également évoquer tout ce qui a été
accompli ces dernières années et qui
s'inscrit en réalité déjà dans la
logique partenariale énoncée par le chef
de l'État qui est le socle des relations
renouvelées de notre pays avec le
continent africain tout d'abord alors
que certains fustigent notre présence
militaire et que la propagande de
puissance hostile s'efforce d'y énoncer
un néocolonialisme je souhaite rappeler
comme cela a été fait précédemment que
c'est à la demande des autorités
maliennes que la France est intervenue
dans leur pays et qu'elle a sauvé sa
capitale des forces djihadistes qui la
menaçait
elle y est resté ensuite pour par pour
prévenir la menace terroriste qui
subsiste toujours dans la région dois-je
parler ici de tout le bien que font nos
militaires dois-je saluer ici nos
militaires nos médecins militaires qui
chaque semaine quand je les ai rencontré
à fayalargeo ou à bécher au Tchad son
certain jusqu'à 800 visites médicales
par semaine sauve des bébés soigent des
hommes des femmes est-ce que d'autres
Milic hostile à notre pays font des
choses comme ça je ne crois pas et ici
je voudrais donc remercier infiniment
nos militaires l'attitude de la France
n'a jamais à ce titre été envisagé dans
une logique néocoloniale notre pays
s'est au contraire efforcé d'accompagner
la coopération des États africains de la
région au travers du soutien du G5 Sahel
créé par le président mauritanien Azis à
l'époque et le soutien à cette
initiative avec l'Alliance Sael voulu
par le Président de la République elle a
uvré à impliqué de nombreux autres
partenaires autour de cet enjeu de la
lutte contre le djihadisme avec la
création de la taxe task force takuba
par exemple la France est aussi forcée
de mener un travail de fond avec les
états de la bande sellosarienne mais
aussi les Nations Unies l'Union
européenne l'Union africaine et l'OIF
autour de la coalition pour le Sahel
afin de mettre en place un volet
développement en parallèle de l'action
menée sur le terrain contre les
djihadistes au travers de l'Alliance
Sael la France n'a donc pas aménagé ses
efforts diplomatiques pour pour avoir
l'attitude la plus fédératrice qui soit
afin de répondre au mieux aux demandes
de états des États de la région
rapprocher ici ou ailleurs à notre pays
une
attitude reprocher pardon ici ou
ailleurs à notre pays une attitude
néocoloniale ça pararente donc un faux
procès d'une écurante malhonnêteté et
c'est aussi une insulte à nos 58 soldats
tombés sur le terrain pour notre
sécurité à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
avec le retrait de nos soldats de
plusieurs pays du Sahel une nouvelle
page de nos relations avec le continent
africain semble s'ouvrir qui sera celle
de la coconstruction nous sommes ici
pour en parler je souhaite en tout cas
féliciter nos forces armées encore une
fois et je ne cesserai jamais de le
faire pour leur efficacité exemplaire
lors de évacuation de nos ressortissants
et de beaucoup d'autres au Soudan cette
année et ça a été évoqué par nos
ministres et et beaucoup de mes
collègues le président de la République
dès son discours de wagadugu a compris
qu'il est temps qu'il était temps de
mettre un terme à tout ce qui pouvait
s'apparenter à ce que l'on nomme la
France-Afrique ce mot valise servant à
dénoncer pas toujours à juste titre la
main mise que la France aurait conservé
il s'est adressé à la société civile et
à la jeunesse africaine qui comme lui
n'a pas connu la colonisation ces
efforts réels d'impulser le renouveau de
nos relations avec le continent africain
je ne cesser de le constater depuis 2017
dans les domaines qui sont aujourd'hui
ceux que le Président de la République a
décliné je salue tout d'abord le travail
de la société civile effectuée par
l'intermédiaire de nos postes
diplomatiques mais aussi de très
nombreuses associations que je souhaite
ici féliciter concernant les échanges
culturels je ne peux que constater la
richesse des relations entre la France
c'est le continent africain qu'il
s'agisse de la saison africain 2020 de
l'ouverture de la future Maison des
mondes africains ou surtout de la
foisonnante programmation culturelle de
nos instituts français et de nos
alliances françaises sur le terrain je
le constate lors de mes déplacements à
l'occasion d'innombrables manifestations
le dialogue par la culture de petites ou
de grandes ampleurs qui se déroul au
Cameroun au Gabon ou en Afrique du Sud
elles sont d'ailleurs souvent elles ont
d'ailleurs souvent lieu sous la bannière
de la la francophonie et de la langue
française puisque le continent africain
devient l'épicentre mondial de la
Francophonie ce dernier se situe quelque
part dans le bassin du fleuve Congo
selon l'expression du président la
langue française est une chance pour nos
relations notamment économique avec
l'Afrique nous ne le mesurons pas
suffisamment je suis heureuse que la
France accueille l'année prochaine le
Sommet de la Francophonie qui sera une
occasion supplémentaire de tirer parti
de ce lien linguistique qui nous unit à
de nombreux pays africains et qui en
séduit beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs
j'espère que nos compatriotes et mes
collègues parlementaires saisiront à
cette occasion l'importance de la
Francophonie comme outil d'échange et de
développement de nos relations avec le
continent africain et au-delà les
échanges culturels peuvent souvent aussi
être l'outil permettant de résoudre des
questions mémorielles qui pouvaient
causer rancœur et différent aussi
dois-je ici rappeler que c'est sous
l'impulsion du président président de la
République qu'un mouvement de
restitution de biens culturels s'est
engagé et qui s'est maintenant étendu à
plusieurs autres pays AF européen ce
travail mémoriel cher au président de la
République nous l'avons aussi vu à
l'œuvre sous un autre format avec
l'Algérie et le rapport Stora qui aborde
courageusement des des questions qui
dérangent on l'a aussi vu avec le Rwanda
la richesse de nos relations culturelles
dépend de nos coopérations dans le
secteur éducatif et je félicite 1000
fois nos lycées français en Afrique qui
accueillent beaucoup d'élèves
autochtones beaucoup d'entre eux
viennent étudier en France et
enrichissent les relations entre notre
pays et le leur je rappelle ici que
parmi les contingents d'étudiants
étrangers en France on trouve dans les
10 premières place six contingents
venant d'Afrique qu'il s'agisse du
Maghreb ou de l'Afrique sub-saharienne
et personnellement j'en suis fier à ce
titre je souhaite souligner et c'est là
l'un des points que nous devons selon
moi corriger et nous avons été plusieurs
à l'aborder
que même ses étudiants peuvent
rencontrer des difficultés pour
l'obtention de leur visa cette question
nuit considérablement à l'image de la
France cela d'ailleurs très
instrumentalisé dans la propagande
antirançaise nous devons à tout prix
faciliter l'ensemble de la procédure de
demande de visa que beaucoup beaucoup
jugent humiliante de nombreux Français
mariés sur place m'interpellent
également sur ce sujet cela nous cause
du tort et beaucoup plus de tort que
l'on imagine ici le renouveau de la avec
l'Afrique je l'ai aussi vu à l'œuvre
dans le secteur de la solidarité et du
développement avec en particulier la loi
de 2021 sur le développement solidaire
et la réduction des inégalités mondiales
et la hausse importante de notre trêtre
publique au développement les pays
africains sont les grands bénéficiaires
de cette augmentation de notre APD et je
visite à chacun de mes déplacements des
projets menés grâce à des financements
de l'agence française au développement
dans le domaine agricole ou dans celui
de la santé ou des infrastructures il
est toutefois important de dire que
cette action n'est pas toujours visible
et et c'est peu de le dire et que les
populations locales ne sont pas
conscientes que telle route ou telle
école a été réparée ou bâtie avec le
concours de la France à nous de le faire
savoir cette solidarité je la constate
aussi dans les engagements individuels
avec le travail magnifique accompli par
France volontaire France volontaire qui
permet à des milliers de jeunes Français
de partir sur le terrain s'occuper de
projets de développement dans un cadre
structuré j'ai organisé à l'Assemblée
nationale ici un colloque sur cet aspect
de notre coopération avec des
témoignages de jeunes parti aider les
autres au Burkina Faso ou en République
du Congo mais aussi de jeunes africains
venus en France en soutien à notre
réseau associatif car et c'est l'esprit
voulu par le Président il est question
ici dans le mode d'action de France
volontaire de
réciprocité le président président a
également compris que le renouvellement
de nos relations avec le continent
africain passe aussi par le
développement de relations économiques
car pendant que notre pays par son
effort militaire conséquent se
concentrait sur le champ de notre
sécurité commune d'autres acteurs plus
pragmatique renforc leur position
économique je salue les efforts déployés
par la France pour engager le
développement du secteur privé africain
au travers de programmees du groupe AFD
tel que ce mené par Proparco mais il
nous faut faire davantage pour stimuler
nos échanges je sais que nous pouvons
nous appuyer sur le réseau dynamique de
nos chambres de commerce et d'industrie
de nos comités CCEF de nos clubs
d'affaires ou de nos bureaux business
France mais il nous faut aussi compter
sur l'expertise de nos expatriés dans
ces pays sur nos milliers
d'entrepreneurs français présents sur
place que l'on nomme les EFE
entrepreneurs français de l'étranger et
que nous essayons aujourd'hui avec le
gouvernement de mieux reconnaître et de
mieux soutenir car en tant qu'élu des
Français d'une large partie de l'Afrique
et du Moyen-Orient je ne voudrais pas
que l'on oublie un formidable outil que
nous avons et qui est la présence des
centaines de milliers de nos concitoyens
établis sur le sol africain qu'il soit
enseignants dans nos lycées français
travailleurs humanitaires entrepreneurs
individuels ou collaborateurs de grands
groupes qu'il soi des expatriés de
passage ou des binationaux installés
durablement sur place ils sont nos vrais
ambassadeurs sur le
terrain nous députés des Français de
l'étranger sommes à leur écoute ils sont
des ponts entre la France et les pays
dans lesquels ils sont installés de la
de la même manière que nous travaillons
beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui en France
avec les diasporas africaines présente
sur notre sol ce qui est aussi
grandement dû à l'impulsion du Président
nous devrions mieux travailler avec
notre propre diaspora dont les conseils
et la connaissance fine de leur pays
d'adoption sont précieux à ce titre les
conseillers des des Français de
l'étranger donc nos élus locaux à
l'étranger sont des atouts précieux que
nous devons beaucoup plus valoriser mes
chers collègues il est inutile d'être
pessimiste concernant nos relations avec
le continent africain ce serait
inutilement décliniste et faire trop
d'honneur aux États qui se plaisent à
agiter un sentiment anti-français dans
plusieurs pays africains nous avons
beaucoup d'atout mais nous nous
apercevons sans doute collectivement que
beaucoup ou d'acteurs sont désormais
présents en Afrique et qu'il nous faut
compter avec cela à ce titre la nouvelle
approche prenée par le président me
semble saine et constructive et je vous
l'assure de très nombreux Africains même
dans des pays actuellement plutôt
hostiles à notre rencontre sont en
réalité très demandeur de France je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
députée la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
d ponteignan pour une durée de 5
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues de notre
capacité à bâtir une belle relation de
confiance entre l'Afrique et la France
dépendra au 21e siècle notre sécurité et
notre prospérité commune malheureusement
en dépit de notre histoire et de notre
langue en partage comme du nombre
important de français d'origine
africaine pouvant servir de entre nos
deux continents cette relation s'est
dégradée et les malentendus se sont
multiplié un immense gâie une la
politique étrangère narcissique
imprévisible incohérente méprisante
d'Emmanuel Macron a mené la France à la
déroute au Sahel et aujourd'hui nous
payons très cher trois contradictions
françaises depuis le départ de
jacquesira qui lui aimait et comprenait
l'Afrique les gouvernements successifs
au moment même où ce continent connaît
une forte croissance démographique et
économique on réduit nos moyens d'action
comme en témoigne le rapport
parlementairire qui viennent sortir la
division par 10 du nombre de coopérants
la réduction de 40 % des effectifs du
Corcé en Afrique mais il y a pire encore
faut d'une vision d'une politique
africaine les moyens qui demeurent ont
été dispersés la cacophonie règne entre
la cellule diplomatique solitaire de
le qué d'orset l'Agence française de
développement qui est devenu un état
dans l'état et ne rendre compte à
personne et les interférences maintenant
de Bruxelles on comprend la déception
des gouvernements africains qui n'ont
plus d'interlocuteurs fiables et qui se
tournent dès lors vers des nations qui
savent ce qu'elles volulent et qui
respectent leurs engagements enfin
troisème contradiction entre la promesse
affichée de sortir de la franceafrique
et dans la pratique un interventionnisme
d'onneur de leçons de démocratie de
surcroix géométrie variable qui fait
perdre toute crédibilité à la parole de
la France comme en témoigne le fiasco au
Niger il y a donc urgence à réaffirmer
et à mettre en pratique le principe
fondateur du droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux- mêm pour bâtir un
nouveau partenariat avec les différentes
nations d'Afrique la France doit revoir
en
profondeur sa politique autour de trois
grandes priorités tout d'abord en ant
nos moyens diplomatiques en
reconstituant un vrai ministère de la
Coopération en augmentant notre
investissement dans la francophonie en y
croyant même et en développant le réseau
des écoles et instituts culturels
français ensuite remettre un pilote dans
l'avion en plaçant enfin l'Agence
française du développement qui n'en fait
qu'à sa tête sous la tutelle du qu
d'orset en reprenant la pleine maîtrise
du processus de délivrance des visas et
en cessant d'associer nos partenaires à
de Bruxelles enfin avoir une vision
partagée avec les gouvernements
africains pour par grande zone relever
les grands défis du continent pour les
années à venir je pense par exemple à la
question fondamentale du développement
d'une agriculture suffisamment protégé
des règles du libre échange pour
permettre l'autosuffisance alimentaire
et des revenus décents aux paysans plus
que d'aide les pays africains ont besoin
ont besoin de voir rémunérer
correctement leurs matières premières et
les voir transformer sur place sans
parler bien sûr et j'en ai pas le temps
des grands projets continentaux qui
pourraient unir la France à l'Afrique
comme la barrière verte au Sahel
l'électrification le développement des
énergies propres bref en un mot une
vraie coopération gagnant gagnante il y
a un demi-siècle en pleine guerre froide
le général de Gaulle avait anticipé le
monde multipolaire d'aujourd'hui et
avait su incarner une espérance pour
pour tous les peuples de la terre quel
paradoxe mes chers collègues qu'au
moment où ce monde est là avec le sud
global de voir ses successeurs et
principalement Emmanuel Macron
rapetisser la France au rang du petit
porte-parole d'une Union européenne
vassalisé par les
États-Unis la France regagnera l'estime
des pays d'Afrique comme ceux d'ailleurs
d'Amérique latine qui n'ont pas vu le
président pendant 6 ans ou du
Moyen-Orient lorsqu'elle redeviendra une
France libre avec une politique
étrangère indépendante au service d'un
monde juste le général de Gaulle
déclarait dans ses dialogues avec perfit
voyez-vous je cite notre pays se
distingue des autres en ce que sa
vocation est plus désintéressée et plus
universelle que celle d'aucun autre la
France chaque fois qu'elle est elle-même
est humaine est universelle la vocation
de la France c'est devrai pour l'intérêt
général
mais comment Emmanuel Macron pourrait
uvrer pour l'intérêt général s'il ne le
sert pas en France et s'il ne le sert
pas dans les relations franco-africaine
tel est le vrai problème de notre
relation avec nos amis africains je vous
remercie la parole est à présent à
Madame Sophie erante pour le groupe
renaissance pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères mes chers collègues c'est
avec émotion que je prends la parole
dans cet hémicycle sur un débat qui
particulièrement cette période est
nécessaire au sein des instances de la
représentation nationale la relation que
la France en tant que nation entretient
avec les pays du continent africain est
structurante tant de nos histoires
individuelles que de notre histoire
commune je crois que nous devons tous
faire attention aux mots que nous
utilisons afin de ne pas raviver les
mots qu'il nous faut définitivement
renvoyer dans une ère passée et pour
continuer d'apaiser et de guérir
certains
autres je voudrais ici d'abord rappeler
comme beaucoup l'ont fait cet après-midi
que l'Afrique est un continent composé
de régions et sous-régions de pays et de
nations si certains ont des les
histoires communes il existe en Afrique
autant de différences que celles que
nous pouvons connaître sur notre propre
continent c'est pourquoi il me semble
important de rappeler que c'est pour
cette raison même que les relations que
nous entretenons avec chacun des pays du
continent africain peuvent être
différentes selon nos histoires et nos
constructions la globalisation qui se
cache bien trop souvent dans l'usage du
mot Afrique a je crois entraîné bien des
amalgames et le sentiment d'un mépris de
notre part si la fraternité avec les
nations du continent africain est
évidente elle nécessite que le cadre du
dialogue soit à la hauteur de la qualité
de la relation que nous exigeons
réciproquement la reconnaissance des
différentes territorialités identités et
structuration n'a nulement vocation à
apporter de l'eau au moulin à une
politique de fragmentation du continent
bien au contraire elle permet une une
photographie à instanté d'un territoire
continent afin d'en soutenir avec plus
de transparence de cohérence et de
méthodes les volontés de développement
et les stratégies de mutualisation des
moyens à travers sa capacité à
construire et développer son union de
manière bien plus complète et globale
que la manière dont nous avons construit
l'Union européenne à ses débuts
l'Afrique nous donne peut-être là une
leçon politique en effet nous avions
d'abord privilégié la stratégie
économique à la construction politique
et nous nous voyons combien il est
complexe d'arrimé de nouvelles
dimensions à notre projet européen là
même où l'Union africaine reste l'espace
où tout sujet peut trouver sa place un
de nos enjeux majeurs qui TR qui semble
souvent fragiliser nos échanges avec nos
partenaires africains et la question
monétaire je crois chers collègues que
là aussi nous avons un chantier
fondamental à affronter il y a selon moi
des héritages passés dont cette majorité
a et qui pollue la relation
afrique-fance le président de la
République s'est engagé sur ce sujet je
pense notamment au francefa et j'en
salue les avancés mais nous devons
aujourd'hui construire un partenariat
c'est une évidence du simple fait que
nombre des systèmes monétaires africains
sont arrimés à l'euro nous devons de
manière pragmatique et technique assumer
d'entrer dans une négociation franche
sur des équilibres complexes sans
simplification ou approche politicienne
alors même que le sujet produit des
réactions
épidermiques nous ne pourrons pas dans
la volonté d'un nouveau partenariat nous
exonérer de ces discussions mes chers
collègues parce que ce sont bien ces
ajustements significatifs qui impactent
directement le rééquilibrage du schéma
monétaire agissant sur les capacités
réelles de politiques d'importation et
d'exportation des pays nous ne devons
avoir aucune hypocrisie en la matière et
assumer la nécessité de trouver un
équilibre gagnant gagnant dans lequel
aucune partie ne se sente laésé cette
nouvelle méthode de négociation et
surtout les résultats opérationnels de
celle-ci doivent constituer un atout
fondamental du développement de cette
zone monétaire qui sera n'en doutons pas
une des zones économiques majeures du
21e siècle en effet l'adossement des
monnaies nationales à l'euro doit
s'inscrire dans un cercle vertueux de
développement économique pour la France
tout autant que pour les pays
partenaires africains il est donc
nécessaire de rechercher de réels points
de synergie de manière pragmatique tout
en étant capable de comprendre les
enjeux du contexte actuel cela permettra
un alignement d'intérêt stratégique de
développement de notre pays et de ses
partenaires dans cette nouvelle relation
souhaitée par le Président de la
République le sujet n'est plus d'être
dans un paternalisme post-colonialiste
laend mais bien une compréhension de nos
intérêts partagés nous avons de ce point
de vue des acteurs français que je
souhaite saluer car souvent oubliés
voire parfois décrier pourtant ils sont
je crois les meilleures sentinelles que
nous ayons et je suis convaincu qu'en pr
qu'en prenant le temps de mieux les
écouter nous éviterions les écueils
dramatiques de ces dernières années je
pense tout d'abord à notre réseau
économique d'entreprise française
installé depuis parfois plus de 100 ans
sur le continent africain elles ont
traversé les crises du continent avec
les acteurs locaux elles ont vécu fondé
des familles nationale et elles aiment
avec autant d'engagement leurs deux
continents ces entreprises ont vu
arriver les mutations les stratégies
d'implantation des puissances
extérieures elles nous le disent elles
ont plusieurs fois tiré la sonnette
d'alarme mais nous ne les avons pas
suffisamment écouté il en est de même
pour nos militaires qui ont vu les
implantations des autres grandes
puissances se développer ces 20
dernières années enfin et je me rejoins
évidemment les les hommages pardon
rendus à nos soldats en opération
je ne peux oublier les diasporas elles
ont été largement évoquées qui elles
aussi ne cessent d'alerter sur la
nécessité de changer de logiciel alors
oui Emmanuel Macron est le premier
président à avoir dans ses prises de
position assumer et exprimer avec une
clarté sans précédent la nécessité de
tourner cette page et la nécessité d'en
ouvrir une autre il est le premier à
avoir reconnu que les équilibres sur le
continent africain avaient radicalement
changé et que nous devions changer nous
aussi je n'ai rien à enlever au discours
de wagadouu mais aujourd'hui c'est sur
les actes que nous serons jugés et là
nous devons aller plus loin et plus vite
dans la déclinaison opérationnelle des
engagements du
Président nous devons changer notre
logiciel mais pas de manière cosmétique
pas de manière cynique ou hors sol nous
devons considérer les acteurs français
les diaspora insuffisamment écoutés
comme je l'ai dit alors même qu'ils ont
des éléments de réponse opérationnelle
ils peuvent donner du corps à notre
nouvelle vision nous donner une capacité
d'action qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
suffisante voire contre-productive alors
que l'intention et la vision stratégique
du discours du président de la
République sont clair et visionnaires
pour ce faire je crois que nous avons
aussi besoin de nouveaux partenariats
sur le continent africain inscrit dans
une démarche de réciprocité cette
nouvelle posture demandera assurément de
sortir des sentiers battus le chemin le
plus efficace n'est pas toujours le plus
direct des détours seront nécessaires
via ses partenaires qui peuvent être des
passerelles afin de retrouver des
relations apaisées et de qualité et nous
permettre de prouver les intentions de
la nouvelle capacité d'action de la
France il est probable que cela passera
aussi et les récents événements nous le
prouvent par des pauses constructive et
une recherche d'Alternativ courageuses
en privilégiant les besoins stratégiques
de notre pays nous devons cesser de
subir d'être en réaction il nous faut
avancer dans la réflexion stratégique et
prospective dans notre approche
multilatérale la relation entre l'aque
et l'Afrique et la France est une des
dimensions d'une ambition dont l'enjeu
majeur est notre vision du développement
humain et l'avenir que nous souhaitons
construire cette relation n'a de sens
que dans la cohérence avec nos valeurs
sur lesquelles sont bâtis notre propre
nation elle doit se traduire par des
actes que nous pourrons assumer en
remplissant nos responsab
abilité je terminerai mon propos par un
souhait qui s'appuie sur la vision d'un
des grands historiens du continent
africain du 20e siècle Joseph
kiserbau pour qui se développer c'est
multiplier ses possibilités de choix
libérateur se développer c'est être être
toujours plus se reproduire et pas
seulement produire participer par
coresponsabilité cette vision je crois
remet chacun d'entre nous au même niveau
elle est un constat lucide de nos
sociétés qui rappelle que chacun de nous
avons à nous développer je formule donc
le souhait ici au sein de cette assemblé
que l'avenir de la relation entre la
France et le continent africain passe
par cette coresponsabilité des acteurs
dans l'ambition d'une humanité partagé
je vous remercie merci beaucoup mes
chers
collègues je vais donner la parole à
présent madame hugette Tegna pour le
groupe renaissance pour une durée de 10
minutes
madame la
présidente madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères monsieur le ministre
des
Armées monsieurs les présidents des
commissions chers
collègues nous nous exprimons cet
après-midi sur les partenariats
renouvelés entre la France et l'Afrique
qui constitue 54 pays et si vous me le
permettez je reformulerai notre débat
sous l'angle partenariat à
renouveler car l'enu essentiel
aujourd'hui est de ne pas être le pays à
qui serait réservé la chaise vide j'ai
souligné récemment dans la tribune
l'importance de la vision des citoyens
africains
sur les affaires publiques de notre
nation et sur la portée des déclarations
parfois
ou trcière de certaines de nos élus
qu'elles viennent de l'extrême droite ou
de l'extrême
gauche crois naïvement que les propos à
l'emporte pièce tenu sur la question des
migrants vivants sur notre sol
n'auraient aucune incidence sur les
relations bilatéral entretenu avec ces
pays serait une erreur manifeste nous ne
sommes plus au temps où la diplomatie se
cantonnait au confort feutré des salons
fermés d'où ne fuitait nul écho alors
renouveler nos relations avec les pays
d'Afrique et plus particulièrement
subsaharien exige plus que jamais de
prendre en compte l'opinion publique de
ces pays c'est en définitive elle seule
à long terme qui décidera de
l'orientation pour politique de ces
gouvernants il serait difficile
objectivement de ne pas reconnaître
l'apport de la France au soutien
économique éducatif sanitaire social ou
encore sécuritaire qui sont réservés aux
Africains sur les volets sécuritaires
nos ministres ont bien développé
l'engagement de la France au côté de ces
pays et je souhaite très Mo aussi saluer
l'engagement de nos armées et rendre
hommage à soldat mort pour la
France sur la plupart de ces sujets pour
lesquels nos ministres ont présenté les
engagements du Président de la
République depuis 2017 et notamment
suite au discours de
Ouagadougou nous sommes parmi les
premiers partenaires et rarement au-delà
des 10 premier en 2021 la France était
le second investisseur étranger sur le
continent africain derrière le
Royaume-Uni avec un total de 60
milliards de dollars de stock
d'investissement
direct certes l'histoire est parfois
douloureuse et peut laisser de profonds
stigmat dans les mémoires collectives
des peuples mais ne convient-il pas
justement à la matière de la faire lire
non pas comme un futur recommencement
qui marquerait l'avenir mais comme une
épreuve à surmon tel une image figée et
visible sur le rétroviseur de la voiture
du mouvement du temps c'est sur ce
postulat que nous devons repenser et
avancer dans nos relations avec
l'Afrique
regardez il n'y a pas de désamour entre
l'Espagne et les pays d'Amérique latine
pas de désamour entre le Portugal et les
pays lusophone pas de désamour non plus
entre la Grande-Bretagne et les pays
anglophones
alors pourquoi donc la France subit-elle
cela avec les pays francophones
subsahariens je refuse catégoriquement
que cela soit car après tout ne Suise
pas aussi le fruit de cette relation
avec ces pays africains qui
réussit ainsi j'appelle de mes vœux que
renaisse le désir de France pour les
jeunes générations et qu'au-delà des
malentendus des erreurs et des fautes
commises
renaisse un dialogue franc et direct sur
les ressorts distendus des causes qui
nous poussent hors
d'Afrique cela étant dit l'offre
concurrentielle des pays comme la Russie
la Chine les États-Unis la Turquie
l'Inde ou encore le Brésil se faisant de
plus en plus pressante et parfois
déloyale et sans doute un vecteur
important dans la baisse de nos
échanges mais pourquoi donc est-ce que
les participations françaises pourtant
les plus anciennes les plus généreuses
ne seraient plus adapté plus pertinente
plus utile avons-nous à ce point au
cours du temps laissé ce dénaturer nos
engagements au point de les rendre
invisibles à la grande majorité des
citoyens des contributions qui pourtant
profiteent à l'essort de leur économie
oui d'autres pays plus que nous
participe à la construction
d'infrastructures comme les routes les
ponts les ports quiutilisent
quotidiennement les citoyens
lamda faut-il donc revoir notre
stratégie globale sur ce schéma et
garder à l'esprit qu'il conviendrait
d'avantage d'associer ces pays d'Afrique
à la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique à la préservation de la
biodiversité à la limitation des
émissions de CO2
nous avons également à corriger l'image
dépinale que les pays d'Afrique
reçoivent de la France qui si elle est
une nation une et indivisible n'en est
point pour autant pluriel et
multiculturel en ce sens il conviendrait
de mettre à l'honneur les grands hommes
de la République qui façonnèrent son
histoire je pense en particulier à feu
le président du Sénat Gaston mon ville
dont j'ai l'immense honneur de porter
l'héritage dans le lot il est le digne
homme d'État qui su avant tout le monde
dénoncer les conditions des gif dans
l'Allemagne naasie dè
1933 avec son discours sur l'esplanade
du Trocadero tout en faisant un
parallèle avec le génnocide des Hereros
et Namas à
Nami alors reformulons nos propositions
avec une approche qui tiennent compte de
l'évolution moderniste des pays
africains des attentes d'une jeunesse
connectée avant-gardiste à l'écoute du
monde et de plus en plus consciente de
la valeur de cette
terre nous avons avec eux encore mais
pour combien de temps la langue en
partage les liens entre l'ASSÉ culturel
socio-économique et humain
profond ces liens sont d'une valeur
inestimable pour construire en symbiose
un avenir commun gage d'un développement
fécond où nos entrepreneurs auront une
place de choix avec un retour
partenarial bien compris en faveur du
tissus économique
africain madame la Présidente madames et
messieurs les ministres chers
collègues l'Afrique a besoin de
nous nous avons besoin de l'Afrique
disons-les lui et soyons davantage
attentif à sa diaspora je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mes chers
collègu donc nous avons fini les
interventions des groupes nous allons
passer aux interventions des présidents
de commission permanent le premier à
s'exprimer sera monsieur Jean-Louis
bourlange qui préside la commission des
affaires étrangères pour une durée de 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente euh madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le continent africain est pour
la commission que je préside une source
d'attention constante et un sujet
d'intérêt
fondamental rien que sur ces dernières
semaines la commission des Affaires
étrangères a a adopté pas moins de
quatre rapports qui traitent à des
titres divers d'enjeux touchant notre
relation avec ce continent ou les pays
qui en font partie ainsi le 8 novembre
dernier
la Commission a adopté l'important
rapport d'information de Michel Tabarot
et Bruno fou sur les relations de la
France avec l'Afrique
au-delà du vocabulaire renouvelé et de
la multiplication d'initiative souvent
bienvenue ce rapport appelle à
l'établissement d'une offre stratégique
plus horizontale avec les pays africains
dans le cadre de l'examen du projet de
loi de finance pour 202 4 plusieurs avis
budgétaires établis au nom de la
Commission ont porté un regard
spécifique sur certains enjeux de notre
relation avec l'Afrique la vie j'en
distinguerai trois la vie d'Élise le
boucher
sur l'aide publique au développement est
ainsi largement revenu sur l'enjeu de la
santé maternelle et infantile dans les
pays prioritaires de la Afrique
subsalienne enjeu majeur vous en
conviendrez la vie d''estelle youssoufla
sur l'action audiovisuelle extérieur a
pour sa part souligné combien il est
crucial dans le contexte d'une mise en
cause multiforme de notre audiovisuel
extérieur de le doter des outils propres
à conforter le lien de confiance avec
les publicqus Africains enfin l'avis de
Frédéric petit sur la diplomatie
culturelle et d'influence c'est attarder
sur l'action culturelle de la
coopération avec l'Algérie relevant les
attentes fortes de la jeunesse
algérienne en matière de culture de
francophonie de mobilités étudiantes et
d'échanges économique notre collègue a
souligner que nous n'avions pas le droit
algérien comme français de désoir ses
attentes
entre lors de mes propres
déplacements
notamment en Côte d'Ivoire et au Sénégal
j'ai pu observer que la voix de la
France malgré toutes les difficultés que
nous rencontrions continuer de porter et
de porter fortement alors je parle ici
au nom de la commission des affaires
étrangères c'est-à-dire ni au nom mon
propre ni au nom de mon groupe politique
mais je crois possible quand même de
rappeler que la politique africaine de
la France appelle une triple Révolution
elle commande de la poursuivre car cette
révolution est engagée révolution du
périmètre car c'est l'ensemble de
l'Afrique et non notre traditionnel
précarré hérité de l'époque coloniale
qui doit mobiliser notre attention et
notre action du Nigéria à la République
du Congo du moambique à l'Union
sud-africaine les grands acteurs de
l'Afrique d'aujourd'hui et de demain
n'ont pas à ce jour fait l'objet d'un
investissement intellectuel et politique
suffisant de notre part révolution des
enjeux en en second lieu comme le
soulligne le chef de l'État la
coopération économique écologique
technologique et démocratique doit être
bien davantage que les affaires
militaires au cœur de notre relation
future avec l'Afrique et cela exige de
notre part des investissements
relationnels et cognitifs autrement plus
massifs que ceux auquel nous nous sommes
habitués voir résignés révolution
partenariale enfin à l'antique relation
d'une puissance coloniale qui n'est plus
et de ces anciens protégés se substitue
progressivement le dialogue de deux
continents trop proches pour n'être pas
solidaire et trop engagé dans la
création d'un avenir commun pour ne pas
nouer entre eux une relation égalitaire
le le 21e siècle
sera euh incarnera probablement le
moment africain
de du monde
les les déboirs que nous avons connu ces
dernières années ne doivent pas nous
dissimuler que les destins de l'Afrique
et de l'Europe n'ont jamais été aussi
proche la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'Assemblée nationale
prendra dans les prochains mois toute sa
part de l'adamento nécessaire que nous
appelons tous dans la relation
franco-africaine je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à présent à
monsieur le Président de la Commission
de la Défense nationale et des forces
armées Monsieur Thomas gassilou pour une
durée également de 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères monsieur le ministre des
Armées monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères mes
chers collègues tout d'abord je tiens à
remercier le gouvernement pour
l'organisation de ce débat sur les
partenariats renouvelés entre la France
et les pays africains permettez-moi pour
commencer de vous faire part d'une
conviction l'Afrique est le berceau de
l'humanité elle en est aussi son avenir
sa dynamique démographique l'explique en
grande partie en 2050 elle comptera 2,5
milliards d'habitants soit un/4 de
l'humanité l'Afrique est aussi en pleine
mutation politique écologique
technologique économique sécuritaire ces
mutations africaines redessinent le
monde et donc les conditions dans
lesquelles nous devons déployer une
politique utile à la France à l'Europe
comme à nos partenaires africains bien
sûr il serait plus facile et prudent de
temporiser mais rappelons-nous ce que
nous disait le Général de Gaulle en 1944
à Brazaville rien ne serait en réalité
plus imprudent que cette prudence en
restant engagé auprès de ses partenaires
la France s'est toujours adaptée aux
réalités Chang de l'Afrique pour être
fidèle à sa vocation universelle au
service des équilibres du monde mais
aussi pour veiller à la défense de ses
intérêts nous avons en particulier payé
un prix élevé pour la sécurité du
continent depuis
1963 255 de nos militaires sont morts
pour la France en Afrique dont 58 ces 10
dernières années en leur rendant hommage
aujourd'hui je veux dire l'importance de
leur sacrifice pour la France nos
concitoyens et plus largement pour
l'Afrique elle-même nous pouvons être
fiers de ce qu' nos armées ont réalisé
ces dernières années au Sahel protéger
ses varés libérer tonbouctou sauver des
soldats nigériens à tongoongo appuyer
les Burkinabé pour reprendre l'hôtel
splendide nous l'avons toujours fait à
la demande des pays concernés depuis
2017 en complément de cette action
sécuritaire et dans la foulée du
discours du président de la République à
wagadugu plusieurs actes forts ont été
posés l'apaisement courageux des
mémoires avec les rapports Stora et
Ducler le rapport savoar qui ouvre la
restitution du trésor d'abomé au Bénin
la réforme ambitieuse pour faire évoluer
le Fran CFA l'affirmation d'une
ouverture plus grande vers les pays
anglophones et lisophones l'initiative
choose Africa qui permet de dépasser un
modèle épuiser d'aide au développement
ou encore le semain Montpellier qui
ouvre de nouvelles voies à nos relations
avec les sociétés civiles africaines
mais réinventer la relation entre
l'Afrique et la France est un travail de
longue haleine qui doit faire l'objet
d'un travail permanent d'évaluation un
de ces questionnements importants
concerne notre action militaire présence
de nos forces prépositionné coopération
défense modalité de nos opérations c'est
pourquoi la Commission de la Défense et
je remercie plusieurs orateurs d'en
avoir fait part a lancé la semaine
dernière un cycle de travail à ce sujet
nos travaux à périmètre continental
cherche à replacer nos enjeux de défense
dans le cadre beaucoup plus large des
mutations africaines en cours et de leur
impact sur nos intérêts que nous avons à
défendre notre objectif est de conclure
nos travaux en début d'année prochaine
et bien entendu nous nous appuyons sur
les débats d'aujourd'hui mais aussi sur
le rapport récent de nos collègues fou
et Tabarot mais mes chers collègues
au-delà de ces travaux nous avons chacun
la responsabilité de contribuer à bâtir
des ponts avec l'Afrique car comme le
disait sangor notre tâche est d'éveiller
nos peuples au futur flamboyant nos
relations interparlementaires doivent y
contribuer pour permettre à nos sociétés
de se parler de se comprendre et de
construire un avenir commun ainsi la
France sera au rendez-vous de ses
valeurs et de ses intérêts je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président donc la parole est à présent
au gouvernement madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères et de
l'Europe merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés quelques
éléments d'abord en vous remerciant pour
la qualité et la pertinence de vos
interventions et de vos
observations je partage de nombreuses
remarques bien évidemment et en
particulier celles qui ont été faites
sur l'importance de la diplomatie
parlementaire et de la coopération entre
nous mais je note aussi que lorsque nous
prenons le temps de nous pencher sur nos
relations avec l'Afrique de façon
approfondie comme nous l'avons fait
aujourd'hui nous arrivons assez souvent
au aux mêmes
conclusions d'abord je crois que nous
sommes tous d'accord sur l'importance
croissante qu'aura le continent africain
dans les années à venir monsieur le
Président bourlange vous l'avez souligné
d'autres aussi bien sûr nous sommes
également d'accord sur les atouts dont
dispose la France et sur la nécessité
pour notre pays de consolider ses
relations avec nos partenaires africains
et d'investir dans toute l'Afrique vous
avez appelé un changement de mîre mais
madame la députée ENAF vous aviez aussi
dit que nous devions pas réduire
l'Afrique à ce qu'elle a été souvent
dans nos représentations et ça n'est pas
ça n'est plus en tout cas un terrain de
compétition ou ou de rente nous voyons
beaucoup plus large je vois aussi un
consensus sur la nécessité de mettre
davantage en avant la jeunesse et les
sociétés civiles du continent de
travailler davantage avec les diasporas
je salue à cet égard les utiles rappels
qui ont été faits par Madame la Députée
lacrafie ou madame la députée Ferrante
c'est vous le savez la grande priorité
de notre politique errante pardon la
mais mais en littérature vous pourrait y
avoir un avenir madame
lesput c'est la grande priorité de notre
politique à l'égard des pays africains
depuis le discours de wagadouu de
2017 qui voit l'Afrique comme elle est
c'est-à-dire diverse diverses et non pas
euh en bloc madame la Présidente Le Pen
nous suivons cette voix et nous allons
continuer de suivre cette voix donc
merci madame la députée tenénia de votre
témoignage optimiste euh il en faut
merci vous êtes là et j'ai
particulièrement apprécié que vous
portiez cette voix optimiste merci
madame la députée et ce n'est évidemment
pas un péché originel que euh de
chercher à développer une plus grande
intimité avec les sociétés africaine je
voudrais rassurer madame la rapporteuse
nous ne faisons pas que du culturel nous
avons multiplié nos investissements
économiques nos entreprises sont
beaucoup plus présentes qu'elles ne
l'étent je l'ai rappelé d'autres
aussi je note aussi des nombreuses
remarques sur la nécessité de mieux
communiquer sur ce que nous faisons en
Afrique euh sur les réussites de nos
coopérations civiles sur nos
partenariats avec les sociétés civiles
sur certaines peut-être de nos
faiblesses aussi je dois aller jusque là
et Madame la Députée Tabarot qui n'est
plus là je partage ce que vous avez dit
c'est un constat en tout cas que nous
sommes nombreux à faire et c'est
précisément pour cela que j'ai augmenté
les ressources humaines du ministère
pour ce qui concerne l'Afrique je
m'adresse particulièrement là au
monsieur le député du ponteignan et aux
remarques qu'il a pu faire sur ce point
nous avons aussi et pour la la même
raison augmenter les budgets dédiés à la
communication de nos ambassades en
Afrique je l'avais souligné mais plus
largement nous avons décidé d'accroîre
parce qu'il le fallait c'était au
combien nécessaire les moyens que nous
consacrions à la diplomatie publique
donc oui vous avez raison il faut être
plus visible assumer nos réussites
assumer aussi que nous avons des
intérêts ceuxci sont fausse
modestie je constate aussi un certain
consensus sur la nécessité de plus
offensif pour combattre la
désinformation et et combattre les
attaques anti-françaises madame la
députée Darius vous vous étiez exprimé
sur ce sujet je salue ce que vous avez
dit il est vrai il est vrai que nous
n'étions pas confronté à cela par le
passé c'est un défi nouveau et un défi
auquel nous nous adaptons nous
avons mis en place désormais un
dispositif interministériel au-delà de
mon minist interministériel de veille et
de repost sur les réseaux sociaux il est
monté en puissance ces derniers mois il
le fallait parce qu'on voit que les
attaques
informationnelles se multiplient et nous
luttons aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
efficacement même si on souhaite
progresser encore plus efficacement plus
rapidement contre les attaques
informationnelles et vous avez eu raison
certains d'entre vous de mentionner le
rôle de la Russie en tout cas nous
allons poursuivre le cap est fixé il
faut poursuivre les efforts dans ce
domaine je partage aussi celle de vos
remarques qui onentr la nécessité de
renforcer nos liens avec l'Afrique et
pas seulement avec l'Afrique
francophone soyez assurés qu' il s'agit
là d'une de nos priorités je le rappeler
dans mon propos introductif oui
l'Afrique ce sont 24 pays vous l'avez 54
pays vous l'avez rappelé notamment
madame la députée lacrafi et nous avons
des atouts partout vous l'avez également
dit nous devons en jouer le président de
la République
est si allé dans dans des pays où on
sort clairement de l'ancien champ
africain Angola Kenya Éthiopie Nigeria
Afrique du Sud par exemple je pourrais
citer d'autres exemples je suis moi-même
rendu dans certains de ces pays avec
vous Madame la Députée et nous
développons des partenariats positifs
avec beaucoup de ces
pays certains d'entre vous ont mentionné
la suspension de notre aide au
développement au Sahel mais je voudrais
préciser à nouveau les choses redire les
choses comme je les dit tant et tant de
fois si nous avons suspendu nos projets
d'aide au développement nous n'avons
pas suspendu notre aide humanitaire
évidemment notamment celle qui passe par
les ONG de même nous avons maintenu
notre coopération universitaire et
culturel nous continuons de soutenir la
société civile malgré toutes les
difficultés et les artistes les
étudiants les chercheurs sont les
bienvenus je le redis c'est ce qui a
permis et je remercie monsieur le député
ledou de l'avoir mentionné que le grand
chanteur malien Sediki Diabaté puisse se
produire vendredi dernier à l'accord
Arena de Berille devant plus de 20000
personnes c'est donc bien la preuve que
il est accueilli en FR et apprécié vous
avez été nombreux aussi à évoquer la
question délicate je le sais des visas
notamment votre rapporteur et le député
pic nous avons tous bien conscience que
dans nombre de pays la hausse de la
demande après le covid a entraîné un
engargement temporaire temporaire je
l'espère de nos services consulaires de
fait dans la plupart des pays où nous
avions des difficultés c'est en voie de
rés rution mais nous n'avons pas
euh jugé suffisant de nous arrêter là
nous avons pris des mesures pour adopter
un meilleur traitement des dossiers de
visa nous avons
demandé un rapport sur la politique des
visas qui a été confié à Monsieur
Hermelin mais avec l'aide de nos deux
inspections générales ministère de
l'Intérieur ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères et donc lancer ce
chantier de fond pour repenser notre
politique de visa mieux combiner
l'objectif d'attractivité et l'objectif
de lutte contre l'immigration
illégale j'ai aussi entendu des
critiques sur un prétendu double
standard s'agissant des coups d'État et
à ce sujet je voudrais être très clair
puisque certains ou certaines ont
indiqué que nous aurions trop de
subtilité au Niger au Tchad ou au Gabon
la France agit selon un principe simple
et le même principe simple nous ne nous
substituons pas aux organisations
régionales nous n'avons pas à juger des
affaires internes des pays africains
avant eux mais nous soutenons les
organisations régionales lorsqu'elles
luttent pour la démocratie au Niger
c'est la CDAO qui est en première ligne
c'est elle qui a décidé de sanction ça
n'est pas la France qui a pris les
sanctions mais la CDAO faut-il le
rappeler monsieur le député tachz cette
au Tchad que vous vous intéressiez
particulièrement au Tchad c'est l'Union
africaine et la CCAC qui ont accepté un
débat de un schéma pardon de
transition dans un souci de de stabilité
transition que nous avons soutenu et
vous connaissez le raisonnement selon
loqual nous avons soutenu une transition
et non pas une succession et croyez-moi
nous passons les messages clairs et
fermes aux autorités de transition pour
que elles agissent conformément à leurs
engagements nous avons particulièrement
condamner les violences contre les
manifestants en octobre 2022 et je salue
parce qu'il y a aussi des événements
positifs qu' ne faut pas vous cacher le
retour il y a quelques semaines de
l'opposant tchadien monsieur massra ça
constitue un signal d'ouverture
encourageant au Gabon puisque le Gabon
est évoqué il ne nous revient pas non
plus de nous substituer à l'Union
africaine et la la CEAC qui sont les
organes compétents et donc il revient
aux organisations de s'exprimer à ce
sujet nous sommes en appui et enfit il
n'y a pas non plus de poids de mesure
dans les Grands Lacs monsieur le député
euh le GAL euh la France condamne sans
ambiguïté l'offensive du M23 et la
présence de soldats rwandais en RDC tout
en appelant les deux partis à la
désescalade je vous disais dans mon
propos introductif que je l'avais fait
euh encore hier et aujourd'hui auprès
des deux parties la réforme du francfa
a été évoqué encore il y a peu par
Madame la Députée errante et euh je
remercie tout particulièrement madame la
députée leenf des développements qui ont
été les siens pour rendre compte de la
réforme du Fran CFA en 2019 puisque
cette réforme est déjà ancienne fin des
réserves de chance placé auprès du
Trésor français et retrait de la France
des instances de gouvernance cette
réforme est faite et Monsieur le Député
leco puisque je vous entends à nouveau
mais vous vous étiez exprimé comme
Monsieur le Député Leal euh faut-il
rappeler que la France ne tire aucun
bénéfice du France FAA alors qu'elle
joue un rôle utile et apprécié de ces
pays comme garant de la
convertibilité de leur monnaie madame la
députée Youssoufa euh nous parlons
souvent en commission du sujet qui vous
importe soyez assuré une nouvelle fois
que la diplomatie française défend
activement Mayotte elle le fait depuis
bientôt 30 ans elle défend son
appartenance à la France son rayonnement
régional et les positions exprimées aux
nations uni en témoine mais je suis sûr
que nous poursuivrons sur ce sujet en
commission et enfin je voudrais revenir
sur des critiques concernant de
prétendus comportements arrogants
condescendants paternalistes venant de
quelques-uns d'entre vous notamment le
député logal mais aussi votre rapporteur
il est évident que de tels comportements
s'ils existent euh ne sont pas deises
ils sont inadmissibles s'ils existent je
devrais dire s'ils existent encore parce
qu'ils ont pu exister dans le passé et
nous devons comme dans toutes les
régions du monde nous comporter
évidemment avec nos partenaires
africains avec respect avec humilité si
le faut en faisant preuve d'écoute en
considérant que nous sommes égaux et
c'est ce que nous recherchons un
partenariat d'égal à égal gagnant
gagnant et j'insiste parce qu'on
pourrait résumer ça d'une formule simple
nous devons c'est ce que ce que nous
cherchons à faire nous comporter en
Afrique comme nous le faisons partout
dans le monde je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
ministre des Armées merci beaucoup
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale mesdames messieurs les députés
je vais reprendre quelques points
peut-être parce que c'est un débat donc
autant débattre et en commençant
peut-être par vous remercier par le
rapport effectivement le le redire
puisqu'il a servi de base à la plus part
des interventions des parlementaires ici
présents et puis euh bon vous avez été
pour un certain nombre d'entre vous
sommes tout assez taquins sur le fait
que les débats sur l'Afrique étaient RAR
que c'était un domaine de part trop
réservé je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
noter moi qui été élu parlementaire dans
une autre chambre que en même temps
lorsqu'il y a un débat sur l'Afrique on
ne peut pas dire non plus qu'on fasse le
grand plein pour les discussions c'est
déjà arrivé au Sénat ça arrive de
nouveau en fin d'après-midi je n'en veux
à personne je je le dis juste que ces
débats sont observés sont regardés et
que de voir aussi peu de personnes sur
les bancs n'est pas le meilleur des
signals que l'on peut envoyer
collectivement quel que soit après la
teneur des conversations et des discours
je le dis de manière très patriotique et
donc merci au présent et surtout merci à
celles et ceux qui restent jusqu'au bout
pour nous écouter alors plusieurs
constats
euh la présidente Le Pen a dit mouvement
tectonique profond j'aimerais rappuyer
un instant sur ce ce propos au fond ça
dépend sur quoi je pense qu'il y a
malheureusement une réalité depuis les
mouvements de libération et
d'indépendance et depuis d'ailleurs que
les accords de défense je vais parler de
ma partie existe ce sont malheureusement
les instabilités politiques 150 coups
d'État sur le continent africain
beaucoup d'ailleurs dans la partie
francophone depuis les les libérations
en tout cas déclaration d'indépendance
pardonnez-moi ça c'est une réalité cette
instabilité là malheureusement on
continuera de la constater tant que
d'autres mécanismes de consolidation des
démocraties africaines ne seront pas là
et d'ailleurs vous dites dans votre
propos et j'y souscris parfaitement et
je vous en remercie si je peux me
permettre de dire pas d'ingérance et on
respecte les souverainetés et d'ailleurs
la boucle est bouclée lorsqu'on a un
coup d'État comme au Mali et que la
nouvelle jeinte malienne dit la lutte
contre le terrorisme est plus notre
affaire on préfère faire affaire
précisément avec Wagner plutôt qu'avec
l'armée française et ben on s'en va et
ça je pense qu'il faut qu'on tire le fil
de ce qui est le respect de la
souveraineté et et de ne pas faire
d'ingérence dans les différents pays
parce que je fais attention à ce que je
dis mais enfin en d'autres temps dans
d'autres périodes y compris plus
gaulienne peut-être qu'on aurait demandé
justement quelques opérations pour
reconstituer une autre offre politique
avec d'autres méthodes pour dire les
choses de manière pudique donc il faut
aussi quand même tirer la conclusion de
cela jusqu'au bout ça veut donc dire
aussi que lorsqu'il y a un coup d'État
au Mali ou au Niger je ne vois pas en
quoi ça serait la faute de la France
alors certains diraient la faute du
président de la République si on fait de
la politique si on est patriote on va
raisonner de manière globale je vois pas
en quoi c'est la faute de la France s'il
y a un coup d'état ce n'est pas la
République française qui organise les
coups d'état ou les contreoups d'État en
Afrique donc ça c'est le premier point
sur lequel je pense qu'on peut
s'accorder mais qui est clé parce que et
là après on revient sur vos propos des
uns et des autres sur la durée des
interventions militaires ou sur la
manière dont sont prépositionné les
bases mais de fait il faut que nous
acceptons que nous avons des forces
armées qui parfois stationnent ou sont
engagés au titre d'accord de défense
dans des environnements politiques qui
peuvent être instables c'est pas un
grand scoop ce que je dis là mais
j'essaie aussi de tirer quelques fils
sur la conversation sur le débat
mouvement tectonique avez-vous dit je
pense qu'il y a une réalité c'est que
désormais on a une concomitance des
risques depuis les mouvements
d'indépendance ils se sont fait
évidemment sous la voûte de la guerre
froide avec énormément d'intrusions et
d'ingérence des puissances étrangères là
aussi tout ça a été documenté par les
historiens on voyait comment leurss à
l'époque pouvait s'en prendre aux
intérêts français au sein des anciennes
colonies françaises des pays qui avait
accédé à l'indépendance c'était
d'ailleurs vrai aussi dans la partie
anglophone et lusophone de l'Afrique
chute du mur et dissolution du Pacte de
Varsovie et au fond s'en est suivi une
actualité plus stable à certains égards
moyennant les coup d'État dont je
faisais état juste oui je je viens de le
dire mais mais merci monsieur le Premier
secrétaire du Parti communiste de venir
dire que que je l'ai souligner à
l'instant sauf que l'actualité a
essentiellement été tournée dans la
lutte antiterro ça c'est une réalité euh
et que les ingérences étrangères des
grands compétiteurs étaient moins
nombreux et pour cause la difficulté du
moment que nous connaissons est depuis
notamment la guerre que mène Vladimir
Poutine à la à l'Ukraine c'est que on a
évidemment un retour des compétitions
des grandes puissances et en plus on a
le risque terroriste donc ça de fait
vous avez raison de parler de grande
tectonique des plaques c'est que pour la
première fois le continent africain est
confronté à un risque terrible endogène
sécuritaire terrorisme amist qui bien
souvent d'ailleurs se mêle à des
problèmes de nationalisme locaux ou
tribaux je rentre pas dans tous les
détails et en plus il y a une
exploitation pour ne pas dire une
manipulation par des grands compétiteurs
qui en profitent pour percuter les
intérêts français et ça je pense qu'il
faudra qu'on le documente de mieux en
mieux et compris d'ailleurs pour tirer
les conclusions du rapport parce que de
fait c'est une nouveauté auquel
l'appareil d'État euh dans son ensemble
pas que militaire mais aussi civil sous
l'autorité de la ministre va être
confronté et donc il faut pas se payer
de mot c'est un défi il faudra qu'on le
relève tous ensemble sur le sentiment
antifrançais vous y êtes venu là aussi
les uns les autres je pense que toutes
celles et ceux qui voyagent beaucoup en
Afrique il y a des députés qui
représentent ici je les salue les nos
concitoyens qui sont comment dire
Français de l'étranger je pense que
c'est un sentiment qu'il faut là aussi
bien documenter souvent quand même il
est très organisé je parlais des
compétiteurs je dis pas que les gens
pensent que tout ce qu'on fait
formidable je suis pas là pour dire ça B
enfin quand je vois parfois certains
articles de presse où on a péniblement
30 ou 40 personnes devant une ambassade
de France avec deux drapeaux russes et
qu'on sait très bien que toutes ces
personnes ont été payées et que tout le
monde entire des conclusion un peu
définitive je trouve quand même qu'on
tombe bien vite dans le panneau et donc
là aussi il faut savoir raison garder
entre une décision qui peut-être prise
par Paris mais que ça soit nous ou
d'autres hier pour demain et la réalité
de ce que les compétitions mais si c'est
documenté c'est tracé non mais monsieur
le député leco il n'y a aucune influence
depuis Moscou chacun le sait depuis de
nombreuses décennies n'est-ce pas bon
donc je pense que là-dessus il faut il
faut se le dire oui il y a des choses
qui sont documentées qu'on peut
constater sur les réseaux sociaux et que
nos services voient bon donc on va pas
mettre en cause la parole de celles et
ceux qui accomplissent ce travail 2uxè
point et j'accélère pardonnez-moi mais
sur les cons pense voilà c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire monsieur le ministre
vous lisez dans mes pensées la séance se
poursuit mais on pourra pas dire donc
pour l'ensemble de cette législature que
c'est le gouvernement et l'exécutif qui
refuse le débat sur l'Afrique Mad le
président non mais je ne veux pas vous
presser mais nous avons une autre séance
qui commence 30 monsieur le ministre et
bien je m'en arrête là alors mais
j'aurais voulu vous parler terminer
votre propos d'accord euh non merci pour
ce qui a été dit sur les sacrifices de
nos soldats parce que ça n'a pas
toujours été aussi clairement dit sur
l'ensemble des bans et ce soir c'était
particulièrement clair et quel que
soient nos orientation politique là
aussi derrière il y a des familles et on
est une armée d'emploi ça veut dire
aussi que si on veut que nos soldats
continuent de prendre risques quand le
pouvoir politique leur r donne l'ordre
il faut là aussi ne pas revisiter les
contours des opérations qui ont eu lieu
quel qu'en soit ce qu'on en pense sur le
terrain politique ne pas en tirer des
conclusions et j'avais réagi vivement
cet été quand certains dans une autre
chambre d'ailleurs avaient parlé d'échec
militaire de Barkan ce n'est pas vrai ce
n'est pas un échec militaire ou alors
qu'on nous démontre où a été l'échec
militaire ou l'échec tactique après que
l'on estime et il y AA divergence sur
ces bancs que la manœuvre politique qui
entourait l'opération militaire n'était
pas forcément satisfaisante c'est un
autre débat mais ça n'a pas toujours été
aussi clairement dit et ce soir au moins
nous y sommes arrivés ça je crois que
c'est très précieux là aussi si on est
patriote trè des choses madame la
députée lacrafi a dit sur le rôle
complet des armées et pas que sur les
questions sécuritaires le service de
santé des armées j'ai pas le temps mais
tout ça sont des sujets évidemment qui
sont aussi présents dans la
programmation militaire et qui nous
permettra de présent no rendez-vous
parce que dans certaines zones il n'y a
que les armées françaises qui peuvent
intervenir sur un certain nombre de
d'offres de soins c'est vrai pour les
populations locales c'est vrai aussi
pour les Français d' l'étrangers et nos
et nos concitoyens expatriés et donc
évidemment vous avez raison de le
rappeler 4 alors Barc puisqu'on a plus
le temps je va pas lancer un grand débat
sur le sujet enfin
j'entends les critiques que l'on peut
faire à
postériori je dis juste que sur ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire ça me semble pas si
évident en écoutant les différentes
interventions si je me réappuie sur ce
qu'a dit la présidente Le Pen pas
d'ingérence pas d'ingérence très clair
ça a peut-être duré trop longtemps
pourquoi pas enfin la réalité c'est que
débrancher l'opération barkane pendant
les opérations de lutte contre le
terrorisme c'était clairement abandonné
tout le Mali à une mort en tout cas
beaucoup de de Maliens et de alienne à
une mort certaine donc ça pose la
question aussi de la nature même de ces
opérations euh c'est quand on commence à
combattre et quand on commence à
combattre à la place du partenaire et
non plus au côté du partenaire B vous
vous retrouvez dans une situation de
lequelle si vous débranchez l'opération
quel que soit le président de la
République parce que c'est pas le
président actuel qui l'a décidé c'est le
président Hollande vous étiez dans une
situation en disant ah bah ça y est vous
abandonnez le Mali au groupe terroriste
armé vous allez livrer Bamako aux
différents groupes terroristes et donc
la difficulté que nous avons eu et ça je
crois qu'ussi on peut dire
collectivement c'est qu'à un moment
donné l'armée française elle a fait
complètement le travail à la place des
forces armées maliennes mais ça aussi
est-ce que c'est un problème politique
je crois que oui on peut le dire mais
enfin quand on regarde la situation
dramatique dans lequelle est le Mali je
voyais les différents tweet là aussi
guerre informationnelle sur la reprise
de Kidal et cetera je pense qu'il faut
être très très calme en la matière
puisque les armées malienne avec Wagner
ont repris le camp de Kidal c'est pas la
ville de Kidal sans qu'il n'y ait eu de
combat bon donc malheureusement la
situation à enfin sur le Sahel parle
pour le bilan français il parle
tristement il parle dramatiquement mais
malheureusement il parle mais de cela
aussi on pourra y revenir alors et
maintenant et là j'accélère très vite
sur la formation pratiquement personne
n'y'est revenu je pense que c'est
consensuel sur l'armement c'est
indispensable on peut pas dire qu'on
veut faire on ne peut plus faire à la
place et faire faire par les armées
locales et en plus leur dire ah bah non
on va pas vous vendre du matériel toute
façon si on le fait pas déjà d'autres
vont le faire à notre place ça a été
rappelé par la députée Tabaro je crois
en parlant de de la Turquie je crois et
que par définition là on est attendu en
disant le Sénégal par exemple qui est un
pays qui va devenir producteur
d'hydrocarbures sous peu qui va donc
être exposé à des risques terroristes
importants dire soit on fait à côté soit
on fait à leur place c'est pas à l'ordre
du jour soit on leur permet de faire et
si on leur permet de faire il y a
évidemment un niveau d'équipement qu'il
faut atteindre ça pose des questions sur
les prix les modèles économiques que
notre BITD base industrielle et
technologique de défense doit aussi
proposer à l'Afrique je le dis ici sans
embage je suis le ministre de tutelle
des industries de défense je les aime
enfin pendant de nombreuses années le
marché africain ne les intéressait pas
et donc là je leur ai demandé
expressément depuis un an d'avoir une
offre spécifique pour les pays africains
y compris avec le trésor être en
capacité de prendre des risques
notamment sur le segment terrestre
notamment sur les drones notamment sur
les antidrone mais aussi le cyber parce
que ce sont des structures numériques
dans ces pays qui sont en plus des
structures qui peuvent être
particulièrement fragiles sur le terrain
cyber là aussi il faudra y revenir enfin
pour ce qui n'a pas complètement été
évoqué mais je sais que certains
voulaient y revenir notamment le député
bencheek il y a un travail en cours
toujours sur les stratégie d'accès port
aéroport comment faire des évacuations
de ressortissants lorsqu'il y a un coup
dur c'est ce qu'on a connu évidemment à
à Cartou au Soudan donc évidemment cette
stratégie elle doit se faire avec les
différents partenaires et c'est ce qui
est en cours entre les étatmajurs gen
des différents pays pareil sur les
organisations régionales c'est plus un
accompagnement politique qu'un
accompagnement militaire en tant que tel
parce que les forces des organisations
régionales n'ont jamais été très
opérationnel façon de parler en tout cas
on pourra là aussi revenir en
accompagnement et puis dernier point de
réflexion pour ouvrir et conclure
complètement sur les Européens qui est
un bon sujet potentiellement pour les
élections européennes je pense qu'il
faut pas s'y méprendre le député du
pontaignan qui est revenu moi aussi Qui
Je Suis qui est quand même pas toujours
le plus européen de la majorité
euh je considère à l'inverse peut-être
que je ne vois pas pourquoi le fardeau
de la sécurité en Afrique ne reposerait
que sur les épaules des Français et donc
je retourne le le propos ça je pense que
c'est un élément de débat qui me semble
intéressant on critique souvent takuba
mais l'idée de takuba c'était de se dire
amis européens avec vos armées venez en
Afrique venez parfois apprendre le
théâtre africain pardon de ce propos qui
est un peu désobligeant je m'en excuse
mais je fais très vite euh et au fond
quand on sécurise NOTAM notamment le
risque terrro ou les risques migratoires
qui peuvent être liés à un risque
terroriste je ne vois pas pourquoi
l'armée française et le contribuable
français prendrait tout donc pourquoi
les Espagnols les Italiens les Allemands
l'Estonie ça a été dit par la ministre
et donc au fond cet esprit aussi tuba il
était pas que pour dire qu'on fait en
européen ça ça serait un peu rapide il
était aussi pour dire qu'à un moment
donné si c'est l'affaire de tous les
Européens il y a pas de raison de ne pas
partager un tout petit peu l'effort
c'était ça aussi l'esprit pardon m la
présente de l'Assemblée nationale
d'avoir été trop long nê pas trop
et ce débat est extrêmement intéressant
merci à tous d'y avoir participé
prochaine séance ce soir à 21h30 suite
de la proposition de loi pant mesure
pour bâtir la société du Bien vieillir
en France la séance est
levée